you made it weird
you itd you made it weird with
Pete what's happening weirdos this is
Jake Johnson who is incredible hilarious
and Brilliant you're about to hear he
has a new movie out on Hulu that is
incredible and awesome and hilarious he
wrote it he directed it he starred in it
I loved it it's called self-reliance
it's on Hulu check it out check it out
check it out he is incredible in it and
in this podcast you are going to love it
I have just a couple tour dates coming
up uh I'm going to be at the Irvine
Improv for one night I'm going to be at
the Oxnard improv on Valentine's Day I
also have my monthly Largo shows if you
want to see me at Largo go to largo-la
outcom all of these tour dates are on
Pete holmes.com check it out love to see
weirdos out at shows it always means so
much and thank you to everybody that
that came to this month's Largo it sold
out it was incredible I'm so glad you
guys were there all right Jake Johnson
let's get into
it I'm pushing drugs on you this is you
right there thanks pal um how long you
been in this place doing this in here
has this always been the no we first
recorded do do you remember Meltdown
Comics on Sunset Boulevard no there's no
real reason you should unless you went
and saw a show there we used to record
it it was near Sunset in laa cool and
that's where we did it for the first
five six seven years eight seven years
eight six years six years and we've been
doing it here for four years we've been
11 years now I it's wild yeah it is and
you just you just started you're way
ahead of the curve I am ahead of the
curve but you know and I don't mean to
focus on the neg yeah but I do kind of
have this feeling of like you know
getting honest about what I want I wish
more people would discover the show
because it's one of the things that I'm
most proud of is is the show totally and
it's really hard when it comes to like
marketing the first thing people want
with marketing is new yeah yeah yeah
toally it's like true of course of Apple
Vision Pro it's new what is that it's
true um so it's kind of hard I say it's
a double-edged sword it's a double-edged
sword yeah because you have a great
Library you've got the content but you
don't have the uh the uh new toy element
yeah it it it's not shiny yes but it is
established yes well it also this whole
world which I'm very new to so even the
idea of doing podcasts I'm still new to
yeah cuz I came up as an actor in a
different time so you're an actor well
I'm trying to
be but the idea of it is even the way
press was different so I hated when
press started getting short form I
remember my first press tour in New York
where I went to BuzzFeed yeah and I was
waiting for the interview and I sat in a
room it was all white and there were
cameras everywhere and they said just
tell uh any story you want and I said
why and they go cuz we're going to cut
it into clips and I thought what the
[__] does this have to do with the movie
I did and that story brought more eyes
to the movie and I remember being like
Oh the world is changing and I'm not
ready for it I think about that too I
watch other people's podcasts and I
enjoy them and I see what they're doing
to kind of I think compete with the
instant gratification of scroll
scrolling life
I don't know when I became Andy Rooney
I'm 44 we're about the same age yeah and
I I just had somebody by the way in
their deep 50s say about your AG happen
to me a lot [__] we're the same
generation and I go like come on give me
something I know I'm not them but I
don't think I'm you yet you are not me
I'm looking at the like topography map
of your face I've seen every smile
you've ever had man we're the
man not yet get close I don't mind I'll
be them when I'm them but don't induct
me into your club now too soon but I do
feel like an old old fart in the sense
that I'm like you know people are like
why don't you edit your podcast somebody
we were we were strategizing we're like
how do we get more okay and not even
just for like the marketing or the
success of it but for the fun of the
game of playing like it I like it I'm
proud of it I've taken drugs I hope you
have this experience meaning like heart
opening things like MDMA and like just
been overwhelmed that I share my life on
a podcast and it actually feels
meaningful yes so apart from anything
else I go like I'm proud that I did that
I like yeah so I actually I think I'm
coming at it different now I'm seeing
the be love too so I'm feeling the warm
in here now oh yeah be love but I think
I'm coming at it differently in that you
have a thing that says Be Rich yeah I'm
like get get that gold boy get that gold
no I love uh I love the game get that
gold please get a sticker that says gold
in those boy that's why you go to
California prospector with the Itchy on
that's why we all came here itchy will
onesies is why we're here with the butt
flap and then you see a hill and you
realize there's no more gold in this
mountain and you look over and there's a
bunch of Fools and somebody's quiet and
you go I think those [__] found
gold is there do you play Red Dead
Redemption by any chance you find a guy
at one point and he's found gold he's
just mining for gold and the game is so
sophisticated that you're like if he's
here I bet something happens so you just
watch him and he goes I found and you
just shoot him in the
face shoot him in the face and take it
you know how much and then a guy rides
into
town has gold and pretends he found it
imagine that guy the level talking
that's our business that is funny that
is AR you sit around you talk about an
idea with a group of people you pitch it
around they pass and then a year and a
half later you see a variation of it
with other people and Dereck Waters
takes your drunken
story just look at one of these any one
of these can be I love you d you stole
my [__] no no I'm kidding I know but I
was actually just with him this weekend
I love Derk Waters I love Derrik Waters
I just I was doing light research
because I'm a fan I didn't have to
research you and I did see that on your
Wikipedia page that you drunkenly told
Derek wat it's the story of Otis Otis
reading he had a really funny thing we
just went to San Fran together we got
home yesterday and Derk and I was the
first time we ever flew together yes and
he did say as it was taken off it would
be funny just based on the origins of
our relationship with Drunk History
because the story is that I believe to
be true the internet has proven me to be
a liar oh this writing story yeah you
were wrong well someone told me when I
was growing up in the 90s so I've told
that story 10,000 times it was one of my
we're all drinking in a bar I got a good
story my dad's been telling me that
Thomas Edison invented the revolving
door every time I went in a revolving
door as soon as Google came out I was
like Dad was dad was wrong and how many
people have you told that to well or not
a lot this isn't the ex the the
usefulness of this example ends there
because I don't I don't do that cuz it
used to bug me that my dad got I got
mine was a buddy told me in high school
the story is Otis reading's wife used to
write a lot of um his music with him
back in the day she didn't get credit
for it so um but they were really
connected they were really tied up they
were going to the air working on a song
they were going to the airport she drove
up to the airplane right before he got
on the plane he stopped and he said no
matter what happens promise me you'll be
good and she goes like you're crazy what
you get on the [__] plane he goes
just promise me she goes I promise you
gets on what does he mean you'll be good
just like be they religious be pure be
good be like be like of light I see just
like be a good person it sounds like
don't go too timing me when I'm a ghost
might have been I I'm not in his head I
just know the story and it is all a lie
it's hard just to know spoiler it's a
lie it's all a lie keep going be good be
good he gets on the plane plane crashes
he does so my buddy told me that when we
were having like a ghost story night
when we were like 17 and just smoked
weed for the first time we all got
tingles I don't like this and I was like
that's amazing man like that's as good
as it gets so I told it in a lot of bars
Derek and I became friends we were
sitting in our apartment my apartment
getting drunk and I told the story and I
thought his eyes were going like wow you
know does this guy have a story you know
and we were just becoming friends oh no
and I was like then in the next day he
called me up and he goes can I come over
tonight with a bottle of booze anything
you want I'll pay and we'll get our
friend Jeremy Connor to film you telling
that Otis reading story and I go why he
went next night next day it was the
morning after and I go why and he goes
because I want to get uh I was we were
commercial actors at the time just
started and he goes I want to get like
real actors to reenact your story and
then get summoned to play Otis red so he
really did have the idea and I was like
of course he did yeah and I was like no
I can't be drunk I have a commercial
agent yeah and then he put it together
with another one of our friend and put
me in the first one as one of the
reenactors with Mike Sarah as Mike
Sarah's first poping and that was like
my first kind of credit around oh so so
Derrick and I are on the plane last
night and he goes
uh it would be funny if we crashed based
on our back story like it all started
you've only ever told die in a plane
crash though he did die that's confirmed
that is the part that's not confirmed as
he said to his be good and all that [__]
yeah I just remember like Bill the
Butcher yes remember which which part of
that story that when he's dying he goes
I'm Proud To Die a real American good
for him and I'm like yeah and then did
he say I pooped my pants you know what I
mean like was he like it's so much time
wild had a great last one what was I'm
tired of being the funniest person in
the room that was do you know good
Chicago boy who good Chicago boy put all
this Johnny Belushi no I'm tired of
being the funniest person in the room
was the last words of Dell close it was
yeah and then I'm sure he also said yeah
I'm cold I'm cold yeah that's right I'm
also can I get more of that cough
medicine cuz my chest really hurts yeah
yeah yeah exactly please give me more
Morphin is everyone's last words and
like be quiet please be quiet honestly
please be quiet shut the [__] up
everybody please I get it I love you
you're my family all you people are
honestly shut the [__] up I'm dying give
me like one minute of Silence before I
leave this [__] Earth I can't breathe
you know what I'm going to want unplug
that be be part mon yeah I can't have a
beep beep I know what I'm going to want
I've thought about it based off you know
relatives who I've watched pass I am
going to have a stage where I'm going to
say load me up with drugs I'm not going
to some people say towards the end of
their lives they want to experience it
want to be around and be present yeah
I'm not I'm going to say I love
everybody but experiencing me
experiencing Joy squeeze my hand is I'm
like and my daughters and my wife will
be like everything okay
great I want you to remember me like
that not remember me going like well I
think there's something about the drug
experience that is mirroring what what
tends to happen as you deteriorate
mentally anyway so it seems natural like
you're already getting [__] up but let
me enjoy but let me enjoy the ride the
beauty of drugs I mean even the beauty
of coffee the beauty of any thing you're
doing the same [__] it just gives you a
little kick yeah so while you're
literally dying yeah that's the time you
say no kick no kick pass buddy you've
been kicking all day yes that's the
whole drug conversation like we all are
doing a lot of different drugs even
affirmation is a drug gratitude's a drug
in La gratit that's funny I was just
thinking about that I'm trying to get a
little bit more serious about my uh
gratitude because it really works I'm
going the other direction what do you
mean in he's going in gratitude I want L
gratitude why everyone being grateful
there's so much to complain about you
want to know why going back what I like
about having less gratitude fewer
gratitude is what it is but yeah going
I'll I'll stick with less is it makes
you grind it makes no not having
gratitude well you're talking about
Drive no I'm talking about gratitude if
you look at a situation you go how's
everything it's like it's great I have
this I have this I'm able to do this
it's amazing or if you go the crowd's
not big enough the material is not great
enough and I don't have anything
interesting then you go well I got to
make the material better I got to get
the crowd bigger and I got to make this
nicer but if you have gratitude I do
start feeling complacent I feel happy
and I go like life is really amazing and
then people with a lot of gratitude will
justify anything they'll go like I have
so much gratitude I go why they go I'm
breathing such a low bar I'm here guys
we're all together it's great my buddy
Eric kste my favorite guy on planet
Earth uh who's not in my family we uh
he's a Mr gratitude we were going to go
watch the football game yesterday in his
hotel room uh we didn't want to go to a
bar we wanted it quiet Derrick's a
Ravens fan we got like some snacks and a
couple beers it was great we're going up
to the room while we got to his room the
maid was in his hotel room bad luck yeah
he goes it's perfect and I go how and
[__] could be this be perfect and he's
like well the room's going to be clean I
go no perfect is as we're walking up
she's walking out but his gratitude goes
right to this is as good as it gets
brother and I go standing in a hallway
with beers getting warmer a bag of chips
is not it's the worst timing the virtues
of ingratitude well I'm with you I I
meaning I can understand what you're
saying
dissatisfaction is a really powerful
thing yes and it's fun well yeah
complaining you mean no working having
that feeling of like well do you
remember there was a line in funny
people where he said Adam Sandler's
character says to Seth Rogan's character
who's starting out yeah and he's like
I'm broke and Sandler goes that's good
it'll make you work harder yeah and I I
so I know what you're talking about I am
going to I'm going to challenge you
though I this I want you to know no it's
coming I'm going to let you finish your
point no you go I want to get challenged
is it possible Jake that you can have
gratitude and in that state of gratitude
which we could also call like an open
satisfied State you can ask yourself
what do I want yeah how do I want to
feel why do I want it yeah and how can I
get it those three questions I think
that's nice and because then aren't you
running on like a just a higher octane
fuel same thing desperation and fear can
make me go and don't get me wrong
sometimes I get in aain
and I have to book guests I have to book
shows
write but I think I'm agreeing that that
works yes isn't it possibly
better to stop and just go I don't want
like I'm trying to write this movie I've
been trying to write this movie for a
long time I have a draft of it but I'm
still there's more work to be done when
I go I have to sit down and do those
rewrites I don't do it but if I can stop
and focus on why I want to write the
movie right and what I'll feel when I
finish the
movie that's a cleaner like what we have
to do gives me paralysis why I want to
do what I have to do will make me start
doing the things I think that's
interesting I have is that as close as
we're going to get to you saying no you
are correct
sir I'm tipping your hat well done
podcast over you
won what if that's what I wanted love it
I don't want you just want to win little
debates you want the other person to go
like and I'm not saying you do but you
just want the other person to go that's
right isn't it embarrassing though I do
want to go back to your thoughts on that
theory it is embarrassing you ever get a
real good look at what you want and
you're embarrassed and if you are honest
wouldn't I be great if you started
crying we're like you've changed my life
today wow holy [__] I mean no so here's
what I feel about gratitude because you
bring up interesting points and it's
stuff I've actually thought about a lot
uh I feel like I'm pretty good at
compartmentalizing so family and life I
do have gratitude yeah uh we were
talking about the outside house places
that mean something all that stuff I
have a lot of I every once in a while
I'll be like wow like this part is great
yeah when I have had moments where I
have gratitude towards my job and I go a
[__] chubby kid with my nose from a
suburb of Chicago got to live my
childhood dream just to be on TV I got
to talk more about the nose but yeah
great nose what are you talking about
who who hurt you a lot of people who
hurt you with that nose Evon uh but it
was a pretty Progressive lovely
beautiful Town beautiful Town they're
calling you what no I'm just kidding not
relive it let's not relive it no I'm
goes to color bars yeah um but what I'll
have is when I have those moments where
I'll go like oh I hid all those bars
that I wanted to hit yes the stuff that
when I was at improv theaters and SCH
and writing my ass off and having day
jobs and grinding there was a bar and
when I hit it and I feel gratitude my
shoulders come down yes I feel the
desire to smoke more pot yes I have days
where I'll go like but truly like I I
smoked pot once in the last two years
because I got the grind back when I'm
feeling really good kids go to school
one hit with coffee a slow workout what
a wonderful
day a lunch where you go what is this
restaurant what do you serve and I go
some place in Silver Lake where I'm like
well this is as hip of a place as I've
ever been a smoothie with a weird salad
and you can also fry the chicken but
you're using an oil that's not even bad
for me and sweet potato fries and I
start going in my friends call him Wavy
Gravy cuz I start going in a mode of
like life is good and if I'm sick and
I'm going to die leaning into Wavy Gravy
yeah but if we're gold miners and we're
Prospectors and there's gold in these
Hills then then the idea is I don't want
to go like I got a little basket and
when I did that weird shift thing there
was a little gold I I like this feeling
of like Live Like You're [__] when
you're working live like you're broke
live like you want it so bad live like
you haven't done anything you're just
starting cuz for me if I go like well
what do I really want to do I think the
hobby is creation yeah and the hobby is
some so for me podcast when I finally
got into it when Gareth pitched me this
idea I said no to him for a long time
and then we I started seeing it more and
I was like oh you could have a direct
link to audience you can have like a
highly produced show you can make a lot
of them and then you can start trans you
can start passing on other jobs so if
Hollywood comes calling with one of
their like [__] low offers yeah that
you go like what is the offer and they
go well this isn't a money deal but
you're with great people yeah and they
go like well there's great people
everywhere and so some 24y old ad is
going to make my schedule I have to show
up 5 hours before we shoot to try on a
pair of jeans that are going to look
like all the pants I've ever worn you're
talking I just wrapped a movie yesterday
that whole game and then you go there's
no money and then when it's profitable
the streamer decides when they pay you
they decide what your Equity cut is and
your big thing is to say like well I got
to do this gratitude tells me wonderful
these people I've been are my heroes are
in the same room as me oh [__] ER
goes like for this [__] money that's
commissioned and taxed yeah [__] pass
yeah there's gold in that Hill there's
gold in a different Hill and I'm going
over there and then you see new people I
love them studying how they're doing it
getting really into it and pretending I
need this to eat and that's what drives
me because if I go what do I really want
to do I don't know but if I go this is
the only way I can quote unquote feed my
family yeah well I'm going to [__]
grind my ass off and the grind is is
really what I love well that's that's
what I okay so I think there's a very
interesting area here and I think
there's a little bit of paradox meaning
yes you sitting at Cafe Gratitude I
don't know where you were chicken
there's a lot of places like Cafe
Gratitude but you're having a smoothie
and your nice salad and you're in Wavy
Gravy yeah yeah yeah and that Crocs yeah
yeah exactly shorts I saw the cargo
shorts before you said it you got to let
those and they're awesome red Crocs
shine yeah agreed and you go like I got
so many different things in these
pockets and that and they were I can use
them all at some point their socks but
you're not using those socks letting
them breathe well who cares I might the
Swiss cheese kind you might you might on
a plane you might them on on a plane not
remember when planes used to give you
socks well they they still they still do
I haven't seen socks in a while yeah if
you if you do the overnight in the cap
yeah yeah yeah overnight all overnight
oh no okay so going over the pond so Wy
gravy you and I agree is a wonderful
place agreed so fun can I say though I'm
going to jump to the third point please
that wavy your ability to Wavy Gravy is
informed by I I think about this all the
time you don't want to do nothing yes
you want to do nothing after you did
something yes briefly right and then you
want the next thing coming no I I hear
that and that that's one of the weird
things that I don't think enough people
explain we want growth yes we want
challenge we want something that's a
little bit scary yep uh and and then you
get this great you also you also want
comfort in that so Comfort it's scary
but you're like but my co-stars are
literal friends or the director and I
are we work together forever so this
person and I are a team but this whole
thing is scary but I think we can do it
you're nailing it yeah because I just
saw uh Tony Robbins talking about the
six needs and one is certainty so my
friends will be there
uncertainty we'll see what happen I
watched your movie last night it was
wonderful and there are scenes not easy
scenes yes that's right great scenes
great scenes didn't like the movie I'm
just kidding I'm kid hey man and that's
okay too cuz I got a podcast to sell but
if you don't like the podcast I got a
movie kid and if you don't like that I
got cargo shorts I got shoes I got a car
full of stuff Pete you got so many Hells
to fine golden no I love the movie
watched it last night cuz you I couldn't
watch uncertainty what it was so scary
doing it everything about it scared me
and then growth growth is one of them
yeah uh giving giving back yeah so when
you're talking about these projects
you're you're hitting all of them I'm
forgetting a couple of them but the mix
Tony that's why we need them that's I'll
help you that's why we pay his ass
that's why we pay him you don't pay him
cuz you remember it all you don't go to
the seminar and go I know what you're
going to say you go I think I got 85%
and I'll give you the 6,500 for the
remaining 15% that is so right on but
you're
saying I'm I'm just hearing a lot of
wisdom here it's like you could Wavy
Gravy yes I think about this all the
time it's like why don't I sell my
house and why don't we move some far
that's you can get a mansion in the
middle of [__] nowhere and just kind
of live simply yeah and I'll tell you
why yeah tell me what happens to people
mostly when they retire dead they
deteriorate and they die yeah certain
people find an unthinkably good hobby
and they weird out
right where you're like that guy lived
for 12 years after why he built a boat
of toothpicks in his garage right and
you go like great and that was the thing
that they woke up and they were doing
like that guy that built the he built
something out of rocks there's a tiny
rocks a bunch of weirdos find some and
if you do that great yeah but I realized
during the pandemic when everything shut
down the planemic oo we're getting hot
let's take some Alpha Brain and talk
this
out let's get into
it but I realized everything shut down
in terms of the business yeah and I felt
I had a call with an executive at Apple
because I had a pilot there and they
said I was like is this over and they go
to be honest we don't know no matter
what we're going to make something and
he goes and here's how it could end up
we could end up sending equipment to
certain actors with stands like this and
you could shoot your singles behind
certain backdrops and then editors could
put it all together that was one of the
plans yeah they were like this was
prevaccine when we didn't know they're
like but we will be making entertainment
and I was up near yosity we were up by
uh my in-law's cabin with my wife and my
kids and I honestly got emotional and I
was like I'm not doing that yeah that's
not why I like this game standing in
front of a green screen in your house
being like I don't like it for the
individual aspect of it I don't want to
be alone in a room yeah I'm not doing I
don't I don't care that much about the
final thing I don't care that much about
it's the process it's the process and
having something to do and and be and
caring about it so much and then when it
comes out I'm not one of those guys
being like I went to Nine Theaters in a
night and snuck in why I wanted to watch
everybody cheer when my name came on the
screen that part doesn't hit me once I'm
done it now belongs to themop who said
that just name names I don't have
anybody in specific I'm just kidding but
that whole thing I don't really care
about the pandemic hit and I was like oh
I'm getting more depressed then I have
I'm like this is back to like
16-year-old depression where I was like
who the [__] am I what is this thing so
I literally like built a cabin in my
backyard because I needed to like every
day be excited about something when I
was done feel like oh I'm tired I'm
accomplished so then I could like sit at
dinner and my kids I could like pull
them in and be like hold that be part of
this at night when I didn't know how to
do the next thing watch YouTube videos
to learn yeah and I was like oh I I
think that's one of the other ones is
growth yes learn a new thing yeah yeah
yeah like put yourself in a spot where
you're behind everybody else and try to
catch up yeah that is so fun it's like
life yes it's weird that but we are just
wired to release certain Feelgood
chemicals and also just longstanding
positive States right after certain I I
don't even want to say benchmarks but
you were like I need a project if we're
if we go back to us at the beginning I
feel like the Gratitude movement says we
were all met to sit in a big circle with
great hippie clothes on and tell each
other how much we love each other and
beat on a drum and go and feel a
vibration of peace and love and kindness
I feel like we were uh brought in this
thing to chase an animal and eat and
bring it back and have people and my
yourself eat and feel really good when
everyone's eating yeah and go like
they're eating because like the of cont
contribution and then somebody else does
a great thing with that meat and someone
else does something and then when you go
to sleep you're like hey you did a great
thing to help me sleep and they go yeah
I know I feel great about myself now and
then everything works and then as soon
as the food starts going out you're back
to getting something else well that goes
back to why I hope you're enjoying doing
your podcast and my MDMA experiences
you're like I'm I'm I'm keeping it
moving I'm bringing a different kind of
animal back exactly right that's exact
and what and for me the real fun of it
is so like for ours I like the idea of
going highly produced and I was like I
like the idea of editing it the way I
edited the movie so we would cut out
like 7 Seconds at places and our
producer Kevin's like is there a lot of
notes and I'm like I know but it's
really fun and then like finding the
type of calls cuz we have a call-in show
and like I don't want to get sincere I
don't want a problem that it's like I'm
a little depressed go to therapist I
want something really dumb but really
important to you so you know when all of
a sudden someone calls up and goes I
bought a pet tarantula when I was 17 I
moved out at 18 to college my mother
takes ambient and now buys pet
tarantulas and we go how many does she
have and she goes no joke 25 and we say
send a photo and there's a photo of 25
transs in This Woman's home in Florida
I'm like that's a perfect call for us
it's really dumb but like really serious
wait when she's on ambient she takes
ambient at night probably misses her
daughter and then goes online and buys a
pet tantula and at this point she's got
25 pet
tarantulas now and but going back to
what we're talking about not just this
story but what was your solution um you
got you got to listen to the podcast
yeah I don't fully remember I know we
were dererk was on that one with us we
were pitching a lot probably eventually
was talk to your mom oh I know what it
was uh find tantula rescues or somebody
who's going to take the Tarantulas and
bring that up as an option to Mom so
you're not challenging there but you go
like 25 is a lot of tarantulas what's a
number that you feel comfortable with is
it seven tarantulas what's a number that
where what's a normal number of
tarantulas nine and make mom say that
when she's not on ambient and then she
she goes you'll admit like I got too
many tantula then you go if we're at 9:
you go I I found a situation a guy's
coming with a truck he's taking 15 of
them or whatever that number is TMT TMT
too many trans that's right that's a
shirt Teenage Mutant no uh but while
we're doing it and we're grinding on it
and we're building the show and we're
figuring out what the tone is and all of
a sudden we're trying and then a new
guest comes in or somebody comes on to
ours Andrew Santino and he I did his and
then he calls me up and he was like get
into video buddy and I was like but
we're weren't friends and he's like your
is good but the zoom's not and I was
like this is such great advice man and
now we're in a studio with K and I'm
like it's just a fun way to go like this
is a whole new game and then UT sends an
email about a guest star on a hot show
after a big thing and I'm like
pass what's happening weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at the per perfect Jean of course I'm
wearing them right now because I'm
always wearing them the perfect Jean are
the best constructed best looking pair
of pants I've ever owned all of my jeans
all of my khakis are made by the perfect
Jean why they look incredible I've worn
them to premieres I've worn them on late
night shows but they're so comfortable
you could sleep in them they have a
stretchy little secret they're made with
2% Spandex and 2.5% rayon which means
they stretched why are we out there
wearing hard unforgiving pants get the
perfect Jean they're super soft got just
the right amount of stretch they're like
PJs you could sleep in them but they
look incredible and they're really
really wellmade I've had some pairs for
years I don't have to replace them they
got great craftsmanship so liberate your
lower limbs with the one and only
perfect genan whether you got lemons or
lentils a three leaf clover a big old
honken eggplant the perfect genan has
you covered go to www.the perfect jean.
NC the perfect J
jnyc and use code weirdo for 20% off
they also got great t-shirts they got
lots of great stuff trust me check it
out I'm also super excited I'm here in
La doing a show tonight and before I
left I was sure to bring my first person
supplements first person have made
supplements that have absolutely changed
my life and Val's life and I'm so
excited to tell you about Golden hour
first person designs Precision targeted
supplements made with functional
mushrooms that aim to stimulate the
body's natural production of specific
neurotransmitters that trigger
activities like energy mood and sleep
what does that mean means take golden
hour and it helps your body naturally
boost its
oxytocin oxytocin is so huge it helps me
get into a sense of Joy connection and
relaxed presence I noticed the
difference the first time I took it
valed to without 15 minutes the effect
has built over time and the more I use
it it keeps getting getting better at
helping me mitigate stress and boo boost
excuse me the Mind Body Connection I
take all three of their supplements I
stack it with Sunbeam which supports the
body's natural production of dopamine
the motivating chemical when I need to
sit down and work to maximize
productivity and creativity by
activating the brain's motivation and
reward system and at night I take
Moonlight which uh boost Gaba the
neurotransmitter that helps you relax
the central nervous system fall asleep
faster and stay deep asleep it's
incredible made with 100% grain-free
organic mushrooms as well as highly
curated blend of neutraceuticals it's a
GameChanger start improving your brain
health and cognition with first person
get 20% off your first order by going to
get first person.com and use code weird
these statements have not been evaluated
by the Food and Drug Administration
these products are not intended to
diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease all right back to
Jake
but five years ago I have to say yes
yeah even though I like the show and
everyone's cool because you go well the
game tells me I have to stay in it yeah
but I think this system is taking
advantage of people not the creatives
yeah and I go oh because of this new
thing I get to I get to say no so I have
gratitude for that but while I'm in it
you shouldn't have it I do have it you
get rid of it you're going to become
complacent I don't have any gratitude
for it anymore you're right I'm a rat
with nothing and I need Che to eat I'm
yeah just so with you and it is sort of
a shame we could go down that path maybe
it's the prospector in the gold and
somebody shoots you and takes the gold
and BRS it to town there is something
pure about coming back this podcast I
didn't even know when I started what it
would become but talk about the pandemic
kept kept us alive yes and then and
creatively alive and creatively alive
yeah forget fresh dude fresh something
to do my wife and I do the Friday
episodes so we have this like
builtin date but better than a
date I'd like to think if you and I had
coffee would be talking like this and
maybe we would I agree maybe we would
it's heightened but it's heightened with
the microphones everybody's heard me say
this a million times it's nice but there
is something strange about this business
you mentioned the commission and the
taxing having just done a movie yeah I
literally came home yesterday right it
was one of the happiest I I was just
telling Katie my co-star Judy Greer is
she's an actress I'm I'm a comedian who
acts I'm an actor she's wonderful killer
and she just had a different approach to
it like she was booking her next thing
and I was like I have five months off
after this and I can't wait to be off I
can't wait I think I would say no if
some in fact I did say no to a couple
things my manager not to this is a brag
I'm just going to own it my manager was
like you have this Hiatus you could fly
to this thing and shoot it and then fly
back and I'm like what are you nuts like
no but some people agreed I'm not saying
this is Judy 100% but she was better at
sinking into it and doing it and you
mentioned being in the trailer for 5
hours the number of times I want to put
this to you please when I'm with my
babies yeah my wife and my daughter and
and I love it it's that's my life and
every once in a while you're just like
God damn it would be nice to just relax
and just have some quiet let's say then
I get to a movie and I have a day of
quiet I'm like this is dope then then
next day I'm like this isn't so dopee
and then something happens I'm on I'm in
my trailer I have my book yeah I have
things I could do I'm one of those
people I can entertain myself I like
doing breath work I like doing all sorts
of different things I don't do any of
them right I'm in there [__] flipping
around YouTube I could watch a good
movie great I don't even watch a good
movie you're on you're on the Instagram
algorithm see what's being sold to you
Clockwork oranged I'm completely oranged
but it's because because my will there's
something about the uncertainty of being
in a room they could knock at any moment
you're not in charge you're not in
charge if I knew I had the whole day
you're a goddamn animal in the circus
and then when somebody knocks it's time
to perform and you go and you go and you
go and but you're something about
knowing that the knock is coming keeps
me from doing anything also because you
have to even if you know the lines every
20 minutes you go do I know him you look
at him again and then you go how are we
shooting this and then you go you open
the door and you go to the base Campa
and you go what time you thinking and
they go it went really slow
today what do you think probably 11 and
you go well it's eight you called me and
it's seven I wonder why you did that and
then you go don't be an [__] you're
just a visitor for the day so have a
good attitude you go sounds good then
you go back in there and you go well
they're going slow then you're looking
at it then you're thinking so you're not
in your own space you're also not the
Creator exactly what it is you're not in
your own also we are not so I I'm so I I
don't view myself as an actor but I'm
not a standup so that was been the
that's been the big kind of catch with
me is I never I loved actors like I I
had two loves I loved writers like playr
like writer writers yeah and then I
loved actors like the Bill Murray's of
the world or the Vince vones when they
were like like that type of comedic act
when they were funny what did you say
when they were funny when I was younger
they were coming up I could do that but
the swingers Vince vongh yeah I loved it
skinny vaugh skinny vaugh I'm not saying
yeah I'm just saying I mean look if it
was a skinny vau but I'll tell you what
he still trim even big was young even
big Von I can guarantee it you get in a
two shot with him or cross cover a seed
that he likes the material that
[__] is going to let it rip in a
way where like wonderful I I completely
agree it's like you watch Mike Tyson
every once in a while he'll like throw
you'll see him like at his age and he'll
be in like a gym training and he'll like
hit the heavy bag he's like cracking
joke smoking a joint and you're like
yeah Mike's just a guy yeah and then he
throws those AR and you're like no
that's Mike Tyson I agree and I love I
love it's like in your movie you say
Wayne Brady who I agree he just made of
talent yeah he is it's like everybody
got like a little dollop of talent Wayne
Brady just is talent and they sculpted a
man does a bunch of different stuff he's
a triple threat he's that guy I agree
and I think Vinnie Von he is I feel a
little bad for shaming I wasn't trying
to shame him I'm just saying there's
swingers vaugh which is like a it's a
young slick vau an animal but I know I
know he still it but I I felt like when
I was coming up I was like well that was
the goal and then I started working and
getting jobs so I came up doing sketch
writing my own stuff moving around
similar to what podcasting is of like
creating little things yeah and then I
started getting cast and stuff and I did
a movie that Max Winkler directed called
ceremony with Lee Pace Lee Pace is an
actor yeah and a [__] good one and it
was the first time where you know when
you're in your 20s and you have so much
ego
and you really think like you could do
everything yeah I was the first time I
was like oh my God I can never do what
that [__] does and it was the
first time I didn't hate him for it I
loved him for it oh wow I was like you
were humbled I was so I was so impressed
yeah yeah he did a scene where he's
walking over a hill and he's got this
big monologue and we're all down here
and it's like a page and a half and I
thought like get coverage cuz nobody
will remember all those lines yeah right
there's going to be some stumbling
that's what I by the way none of that in
your movie I'm looking for those piec
together performances nothing makes me
angrier agre where you see I've also
been in the edit and I've built
someone's performance and then they're
like celebrated and I'm like yeah we
saved your ass we you never gave me a so
in terms of directing I love actors
acting so I love two shots I love Cross
coverage and I like using entire takes I
don't want to have to save you but so
Lee Pace comes out after his first take
I was in the scene with Ang Gano and uh
all these other actors who were great
and we were all like [__] a man
welcome to the show like you crushed it
yeah and I I was looking at I'm like oh
like you're excellence and the director
Max Winkler goes so great so great we
got it we got it but if we do it again
the seventh line and Lee was like the
one that starts with like the pancakes
and I was like the [__] is he a robot
and he goes speed that one up a little
and then he goes then you could slow
down until you get to around like the
11th you know what I mean but and he
goes like this yes yes yes the water I
not making a joke I thought they were
doing a bit it sounds like a bit it was
so technical that it was as if leeace
was a robot it was code and I honestly
thought it was a joke to you know like
sometimes you do like a really good take
and you know you crushed it the other
person know you're in a two you both had
a great scene and then the director goes
like you guys are going with that take
it's like the soft mean joke yeah which
I don't think is mean it's fun yeah so
you just go like yeah I think we'll try
that and they're like
okay so I thought they were doing that
version of a joke yes he did the note
and it made it better wow and I remember
going like I just I'm not not that and I
love that and in mine literally before
the first take Max goes like you know
the lines are the lines do do what you
want to do and I was like ow you didn't
say that to Lee cuz he's an actor you
say it to me cuz I'm this other thing a
performer who knows I but what's
confusing to me Jake yes is that I think
you're a I'm not just saying this I
think you're terrific thanks bu I also
want to give you a very specific
terrific compliment about your terrific
is that you know I wrote my own show and
and I feel like when I watch it oh
thanks I when I watch it it's probably
just me I hope but I can feel Pete the
actor in the scene and also Pete kind of
watching yeah yeah yeah yeah totally
yeah same with me so when I watch things
like I gave Seth McFarland name drop the
same compliment that Orville he does
doesn't seem to be involved except as an
actor he's just kind of in the scene and
that's what I want to say about
self-reliance and I don't know you're
let me can I jump in really fast because
I have a funny way there's a compliment
coming but it's really specific to what
you just said it's
really so it's really funny you say you
saw yourself watching yeah because and
angry sometimes I'm like I'm mad that
this guy you're now he's not doing it
right or this isn't happening right so
as an actor I'm always watching
because I I don't get competive with my
scene partner so if I'm in aene with
Vince vau I want that [__] guy to
roll because I know we're both going to
win if you're in a winner you win if
you're and this goes back to the Dell
close from the beginning make your scene
Partners funny so Max Greenfield uh
Schmidt from New Girl I sent him an
early cut and he was like all right man
I watched your [__] weirdo mushroom
movie he's like good stuff and then he
goes like it's a mushroom trip like you
eat mushrooms and then you made this
movie and he go does not feel that way
to me NE but what he said which was
really funny he goes you're really good
and it besides when you're with the
homeless guy and then you're just Jake
as a fan watching your favorite actor in
the world and I go like you're not wrong
Biff wh yes that scene like with me and
Maddie at the restaurant where we're
first on the date and he's behind us
yeah well what was supposed to happen as
written we go in there I go I'm with her
now I'm good and he goes like okay and
goes to another table Biff whff was
crushing so hard that I go you know what
we're going to do I'm the director the
beauty of dirting as I get to make these
Choices put a chair in all of my shots
and put Biff behind me and Biff goes
what would you like me to do and I go
just listen and react honestly if you
feel like eating eating just stay in it
yes he choose I said just be in it so in
the scenes when she goes I go like let's
you know do this and she goes should we
well instinctually then as Jake I just
wanted to go to be to Biff cuz I liked
him so much so I'd go like what do you
think everything he's just doing he's
just reacting
and all is Jake being like everything
about this guy but when I back to I'm
back in the movie when I'm looking at
him yes the joy that [__] dude
brought me yeah that I was like oh he's
so and also my tone of the movie was
really weird and as a director you as
you're pitching it you know it you don't
know it yeah you pretend to know it then
you start casting it and you're like I
hope I know it m when Biff whff got to
set I knew my tone stop saying Biff
whiff
stop saying that I can't and he also
sent to me a bunch he goes because we
got close we and he was like you know
what one of these days you've earned it
I'm going to tell you my real name still
haven't heard it and I still love Biff
whff but when he what if it's Walter oh
I'd be so happy everything about him but
when he came I was like now I know my
movie and I would tell other actors
where they're like you know the family
stuff how intense should we play it I'd
be like well Biff's in it and how Biff's
playing it is right so you're int tense
but we're not going to win awards for
this movie we're going this is our this
is our vone we want people to laugh and
go on the ride and I would think to him
at times where I'd be like I'm getting
heavy but Biff is going to be in the
next scene
yeah and the movie in the opening
credits is going to have like Andy
samber Chris Lloyd Anna Kendrick yeah
Biff whiff so I'm like this is what it
is when his name came on the screen I
was like how do I know that cuz I I
watch uh I think you should leave Tim's
the best and for those of you who don't
know who B wh is he's the older guy he
plays Santa yeah and and he always seems
to be if he's not improvising then he's
the greatest actor in the world but he's
always right on the line he's bringing
so I hadn't I hadn't seen Tim show until
after uh the casting director
recommended Biff and so we did auditions
stop saying Biff I can't notice how many
times I said tarantulas before there's
certain words that just are great Biff
wh but I was seeing a bunch of old man
homeless actor types all of them played
it the same way they were all actors
it's a person without a home it's heavy
it put a [__] 100 pound weight on my
movie in a way where I'm like I don't
know what this movie is where they' be
like I'll Shadow you I was like I hate
this movie and I don't know what I'm
making because I think it's funny and
light but these guys are doing this
scene where they're like you just
started calling me Walter I was like
what an [__] Tommy is yeah yeah yeah
Biff shows up with suspenders on a
fedora the big beard he's got his teeth
in and I go like do those come on he's
like yeah I go do you feel comfortable
take him out he's like I take him out
every time I eat and then I go he starts
doing his lines and I was like oh my God
like you got whiffed you're I got
whiffed he was the first person I got
approved by MRC I was like before we go
into casting I said to them I go like we
got to know we're on the same page
picture this I go is he approved and
they were like yes of course I was like
now we got a
movie without him I'm [__] cuz if it
was a heavy performance or even an
overly serious performance or medium
yeah if he's not say about your movie uh
I
don't typ well no I think I do I watch
movies like this yeah the premise is set
up for those of you that it won't ruin
it no a guy is inducted into a game yes
where he will be he has to survive 30
days yes Hunters are chasing him yes uh
we don't know any about these Hunters
except that they're deadly and the the
caveat is if you're with somebody cuz
your character says well that'll
traumatize my mother if she watching me
get killed they say they won't kill you
if you're with your mother your
character goes well that seems like a
pretty big loophole and Val and I my
wife we loved every moment of it I
actually G speaking of my movie I wrote
down the working title of my movie is
bliss even though there's already a
movie called Bliss and I wrote down I
wrote myself an email and I wrote a
version of bliss where you get to the
inciting thing faster yeah yeah yeah
totally and that's another compliment I
want to give your movie is like it gets
to it fast real fast do you watch the
killer the killer possibly I'm not C
titles fast Bender no oh it's great that
movie Al there's there's a new trend in
movies where again speed it up we speed
it up well I'll tell you why get get to
the fun fast who we competing with
everything that's [__] licking your
butthole the well also videos that are
really funny and fast that's ever been
done they're licking your but hole yeah
and guess what you want to watch
self-reliance or Gone With the Wind yeah
and if you haven't seen Sopranos that's
there too so if I give you a boring nine
minutes where I'm taking my time yeah I
better have I better be Scorsese yeah or
I better be somebody that you go I'm
willing to spend 3 hours because you're
such a genius if you're not that
although you better dance your movie
again another compliment earned it could
have gone slower because I love the
fisheye or whatever you call that lens I
thought that was awesome yeah Adam Sil
dp's inredible shut up sorry you did
it I didn't even like pretending to say
shut up to you I'm too I'm a little too
sweet I like it I like I like you like
the
bite shut the [__] up yeah let's go
let's make something together these
goddam now we're starting okay but you
do this thing with the lens is it the
lens yes it's it's
so it's in camera it's really cool it's
really cool it's meant to make you feel
a little out of touch while you're
watching every you're a little bit in
very similar to the thing that I'm
working on is like there needs to be two
looks to this movie before and after and
you did that yeah and I was like wow I
haven't seen it done like that it
reminded me of Jesse James have you seen
the assass that was our reference shut
the [__] I knew it yeah because they do
that fisheye well it's the same thing
it's the old lens yeah and it's what it
does is it BL blurs the outside and then
little things come into Focus but the
focus changes and you don't get to
control it so you shift it so the magic
of It kind of controls a little bit so
you're in and out of reality but it's
also reality it's not too crazy no [__]
with your brain a little bit maybe I am
complimenting my attention to detail but
I don't know if most people you notice
that the door frame at the beginning is
arked yes and you're like why is it
arked yeah oh it's cuz it's a fisheye
kind of lens so anyway the the opening
of the shot and your DP what was his
name Adam Silver Adam Silver yeah well
he did a great job and you could have
gone slower yeah and that opening you're
in bed and you're getting up yeah and
the light is coming in and I was like
what a nice shot totally I just modern
movies just yeah they're not doing it
they're not that that was sunlight or
was it it seemed like it was real
sunlight and I was like it's gorgeous
thank you it felt real and I also
appreciate a little things like showing
your morning routine over and over
although your phone should have been
plugged in yeah you're not
wrong but I'll tell you what shut up I
am wrong it's stupid it's stupid that
was so stupid I regretted saying it
immediately well but here I wanted you
to know I watched your movie carefully
well I can tell and I I truly appreciate
it and you could have gone slower and
you do so many montages and they all
work that at the end no spoiler every
relationship is earned and when you
think why does he like Anna Kendrick
well we saw it yeah that's that scene
where you're putting her up on your feet
I'm like well that that was 45 minutes
of movie yeah yeah yeah it's just like a
little moment a little moment so thank
you buddy I appreciate it and I
appreciate you actually watching and
knowing for me when you talk about when
you watched yourself on the show and you
saw where you were mad and you said
where you were watching yeah I just see
on this where in terms of what we were
talking about earlier about t Robbins of
challenging yourself and learning yeah I
was underwater this whole movie really
so in terms of learning and going I
would be like I have an idea I don't
know how to do it even editing when we
first sat down to edit I was like like I
feel like I should know more than I
[__] know at this point and
everything felt like a challenge so all
I see with this movie is I wish I could
be starting it now cuz now I feel like I
know what to do with it so like my third
act I if I could do it again I would so
we reshot a lot of stuff we we went to
South by Southwest and this goes back to
like the grind and gratitude uh we made
the movie for 5 million bucks uh
Paramount paid for it through MRC so we
had distribution through Paramount we
had an international deal they were
setting up the movie was going to recoup
so part of the business that a lot of
people don't know is some of it's rigged
to be fine yeah so this one with this
cast and this premise and this cost and
this cost we're going to be fine yeah so
there was no talk of festivals there was
no talk of any of it so then I thought
like well I want to go to a festival
because I done other Indies that I
haven't and you miss that kind of spark
so they said we're not submitting to
Sundance spark experience no so I made a
movie during the pandemic called ride
the eagle which was a movie we made for
$250,000 in literally my backyard and
then when it went to the festivals I
thought I don't want to go to the
festivals cuz it's just a business expo
I think we could skip that and send it
straight to buyers and we did and we
sold it but it didn't have that there
was a group of people who saw it
together and got it excited and got a
buyer excited yeah so I was like good
good oldfashioned I call that Avatar
when there's like a tribe of people that
unite around a tree but also good
oldfashioned sales yeah if I come to
your door and I say I have a great
vacuum for you you're a little bit
afraid I'm going to come in mhm and you
go like I kind of want a vacuum but I
don't know if it's real I don't know who
this [__] guy is his tie seems weird
his Vibes a little off if you go to a
place and there's a 100 people watching
and everybody's excited and people line
up you'll go I'm lining up too nothing
draws a crowd like a crowd Del close
last
words lot of Dell stuff it was all when
well in a a big D guy I'm not a big D
guy cuz you're standup but I went to
Chicago to do improv let's not forget
what we're talking about but the reason
I'm not a big Dell guy is because he and
I love him and have full respect when I
got there he had just passed so he
became the symbol of you missed it and I
hated that feeling I just I resented
everyone that was in the Dell club and I
was not in the Dell Club same thing
happened when I moved to New York a lot
of great standup rooms had just closed
and they were like you missed it I'm
like a lot of my career was me showing
up right after when it ended and then I
realized there were other things
starting that became the things that
ended when other people showed up but I
didn't know that that's something you
figure out later but everybody used to
be like well Dell if you didn't know him
you'll never know and I'm like 100% I'm
saying this as Dell close each [__] cuz
what he was teaching wasn't totally come
sit by my feet it was here and now it
was like let's get wild let's get real
let's get excited that's as of I feel
the same way I'm not trying to be weird
ramas one of my great teachers he died
and people are like oh he's gone he's
gone what are you talking about this is
literally the be here now guy here and
now is as available as here and now will
ever be exactly right so shut the [__]
up same with Jesus same with Buddha
Muhammad doesn't matter what are you
doing acting like whatever isn't it
weird that the awareness that's looking
out pick your favorite person yeah their
eyes is the same awareness that's
looking at your eyes it's right here yes
but here's the catch because I'm always
goingon to be this guy too first of all
you're right I'm feeling emotional yeah
second of all here's the catch can't
wait grateful
de wonderful thing that happened and we
missed it so in
1994 or five I had I was dating an older
woman nice
thanks it's cool lost my virginity to
her
no yeah she was older and she was Wise
Wise in the ways of the sheets she
showed me the
way anyhow she was older she was cool
she was into the
dead and she took me with like her older
friends we went to see a dead show I saw
Jerry Garcia saw yeah I was smoking
joints and eating grilled cheese
sandwiches in the parking lot I was
surrounded by the dead I had a cousin
who traveled with them for a while so we
knew people we knew that end of that
world in the '90s we had already missed
it but I tasted that thing with that
original group and the old heads who
you'd be like that guy's like 65 years
old he's been traveling with him since
he's 18 cool they all live in that van
whatever right and you saw it you you
smelled it right let's be honest you
smelled it and I'll be honest what was
nice about it is when I was stoned and
the weed got on top of me I felt very
safe and I realized oh that's what this
is partly about a community to keep you
safe and you can trip out hereit and no
one's going to [__] with you like there
might be one tweaker but the group will
weed them out because they want this to
feel like when you're high we're all
golden retrievers we might have dreads
but we're golden retrievers it's a
safety net it's a safety net home wasn't
right your life wasn't right Society is
not right you are safe here in a pack
wow and while you're here listen to a
song that should be 4 minutes that goes
on for 25 and just goes
like and your dancing doesn't have to be
good just go like this no one's judging
you yeah it's all love right yeah yeah
it was UN ated at 14 or 15 whatever age
I was I was like well this is a lot
better than House of Pain or whatever
trash I was listening
to I was like let me put down my other
CDs and this might be it long story
short that made me real really have I
don't I'm not a big fomo person but I
watched that the Amazon Prime thing on
the dead and I was like yes same but
even in the '90s it was over yeah so you
would see the old guys and you would go
like when you guys were young and so
were they young this must have been
magic yeah yeah yeah cut to
2021 a new version of it with John Mayor
is going to doing tours and there's a
new generation of people who will say
yeah the data is still going it's the
same thing yeah and to me I go you're
living in a world of
spin I get that you want to experience
it I get that the basis is there this is
a new thing and this is cool be psyched
about this new thing but it's not the
same but it's not the dead John Mayor is
your Garcia and you could like mayor but
then you go to those same people yeah uh
like they're like I love the dead I've
always loved the dead it's like we
haven't always is you're 35 and then
they go like well I've always been I go
you go to John Mayor solo concerts
bodies of Wonderland you like that they
go no I'm not a mayor guy and I go yes
you are this is Mayor this is Mayor and
he's [__] cool and you like him and
they all like him but you're going to a
mayor and Friends concert yeah and
they're doing covers of great and so for
me the only time that gets me annoyed
cuz I missed Dell but my brother and I
were inov guys growing up you missed him
like we I did the same thing as you yeah
always heard about him since I was a kid
always thought when I got old enough I
would study under him the idea of Dell
was so he's the genius and teaches you
how to do it right and if you're not
touched by it you're always off yep well
the idea of now being like there's a new
guy and he is Del it's not right just
because you read his book doesn't make
you it's different right and so I like
the I that feeling but I don't ever want
the spin or the happiness or what you
want to pretend it's still
happening episode is also brought To Us
by our friends at armra you guys know
I'm always obsessed with ways to
strengthen my immunity as well as my gut
health as well as my fitness endurance
metabolism as well as hair and skin
Radiance and I recently discovered one
product that does all of that and it
couldn't be easier to take I just add it
to my smoothie I don't even notice it
but it does so much it's Arma colostrum
colostrum keeps coming up in
conversations with my friends what is it
it's the first nutrition we receive in
life and contains all of the essential
nutrients our bodies need to thrive
talking about reactivating hair growth
and glowing skin by reducing
inflammation and puffiness in your face
and neck as well as stimulating stem
cells to produce collagen and increase
elasticity so it makes you give gives
you that glow talking about your
metabolism and fortifying gut health so
you feel less bloated and lighter while
replenishing your microbiome stabilizing
blood sugar and accelerating fat burning
as well as fueling your Fitness
performance and and your recovery which
I'm 44 now that's so huge and I've
noticed the difference right away so
easy Arma colostrum is a proprietary
concentrate of Bine colostrum that
harnesses over 400 living bioactive
nutrients that rebuild the barriers of
your body and fuel cellular health for a
host of research-backed health benefits
it's wholly natural sustainable and was
developed with the highest Integrity
grass-fed in the United States and they
guarantee the highest potency and
bioavailability of any coloss on the
market for results that you can actually
see and feel I've been using it for
months now and I am sold so we've worked
out a special offer for weirdos receive
15% off your order by going to tr
ara.com weird or enter weird for 15% off
your first order that's TR r
ym
a.com weird support your body support
the show also brought To Us by our
friends at element lmnt I was actually
just talking to someone who takes it
they kept calling it lmnt and I'm like
it's element but I get it it's lmnt
element healthy hydration isn't just
about drinking water it's about water
plus electrolytes which makes sense when
you sweat you lose both sodium and water
and both need to be replaced to prevent
muscle cramps headaches and energy dips
and every morning I get up and chug one
big old glass of water with element in
it and it boom wires me dials me into my
day and gives my body what it needs the
solution to getting uh through your
workout isn't just drinking enough water
it's optimizing the water that you're
drinking element has become a huge part
of my wellness program I drink it
sometimes at night I love the chocolate
salt flavor uh it's it's a delicious way
to get magnesium pottassium and that
sodium into your body for health
performance and energy giving you that
boost it gives me a wonderful boost it
also tastes amazing and uh I love the
the watermelon salt flavor and I love
the chocolate salt flavor if I'm
drinking it hot and gets me drinking
that water and getting those nutrients
and those minerals that I need element
has come up with a fantastic offer for
us I just gave it to some friends who
drink it after their workout and they
say it basically gets them like
vibrating they feel so good go to drink
LM nt.com weird use promo code weird to
get a free sample pack of all the
flavors with any order when you order
and if element doesn't exceed your
expectations they have a no questions
asked refund policy you don't even have
to send it back so support your body
support the show go to drink lnt.com and
get your free sample pack with any
purchase that's drink lnt.com weird all
right back to
Jake I you know it's very similar to our
earlier conversation and it's another
Paradox meaning it's like have
appreciation for what you have yes and
what you're doing but also for the fun
of it yes for the meaning making quality
of it acknowledge that it's not what it
was it's and it's to and it's different
and what this is you like yeah but this
cuz also that scene now is not what the
old thing was but it if we're talking if
it's all relative if if we can just be
completely grateful as if your movie
wins an I know you're not going for a
I'm say if we're doing that it strips we
need to have rules yeah I we have but we
have to have rules to our gratitude too
that's what I'm saying there needs to be
a clock on the game there needs to be
found I totally agree and then with that
cuz when I say that I do have gratitude
I just think we've changed it to a world
where I'm like we're all [__] talking
out of our asses like well I think
you're we have a similar disdain for I'm
not a
affirmations person I think it's very
weird to look in the mirror and say I'm
happy I'm happy I'm happy I think it's
much more powerful to get real and be
like there's a lot of unhappiness here
you know what my wife taught me that
changed my life she goes if I'm having a
[__] day and I'm just you know grumpy
pinch traveling just don't feel like and
she goes in moments like that God it
could make me cry she just goes and I
think she learned it from our friend Mir
by star but it was like or Tara Brock
maybe isn't it beautiful that I want to
be better yeah you start there you just
go like I'm judging I'm negative I'm
nasty and there is another part of me
going like I I would like to be better
than I'd like to be better and instead
of going but I'm not and it sucks I'm
failing you just go like put your focus
to the part of you that would like to be
better that that really you know I think
we say similar things in slightly
different ways and I agree with I I
think we are going to come to the end of
both saying you're right because I
really and I know this is a weird thing
to say but I really like to lose as much
as I like to win and I think losing
really matters so some people say like
with my movie for example so anyhow we
get to southw self reliance here on Hulu
yes here on Hulu this is
Hulu amazing congrats I like the Hulu
thing where it goes makes me feel like
I'm hiding under a table at a party I'm
not invited to and I can kind of hear
the D of chatter that's a druggy
dreamy it's it's a mind [__] they're
trying to do to get you into it it's not
Netflix it's so similar it is simar now
that you do both sounds there's one guy
doing both of them yeah Hulu is under
the table from an alien it's the same
thing very similar it's we're saying the
from the outside how does this streamer
it could be anything it could start with
h it could start with no sound one goes
and the other one goes they're the same
but is yes different it that that has a
you're [__] here dude yeah yeah yeah
Netflix
yeah and Hulu is a little
more it's expansive well it's also
smaller I think it knows it it's telling
us what the sound of course it knows at
the numbers I know Evil Empire and a the
sound says look at our numbers it's
billions and billions served on the
McDonald's s 100% right that's that's
what that sound is but Netflix knows
what it is and it's the right sound for
what it is what is the sound of Disney
plus though there is no sound cha-ching
is yeah gotcha $40 for a churro but
you're pretending it's your childhood
happiness chaing I'm in the happiest
place on Earth but everybody here is
overweight eating Churros for $1,000
chaing who said that there was some this
actually goes back to what you were
saying about losing yeah that they I
heard Alan Debon de button say that he
was quoting somebody else saying that
there's nothing more uh that there's
nothing that creates more rage than the
LIE of Disneyland yeah and it's because
Disney really depresses me I'm not a
Disney adult I am I I'm I'm not okay I
know what you're talking about and I'm
not that I can go and love it yeah but
if you go to the happiest place on Earth
and you don't feel it yeah it creates
this rage as opposed to and this is all
pro Disney but I know but it's all the
same stuff because what they're selling
is because the sign tells you it's the
happiest place you're spending money you
don't have if it's the happiest place
[__] churros are free you're in we
fig it's the H you can't say the
happiest place and this family's working
their ass off and all the kids want the
same [__] and I know because of my kids
if someone's wearing those [__] ears
want the ears well those ears are
costing you 80 hours of your job this is
not the happiest place this is the
biggest hustle on [__] Earth can I
say go I I love that tying into what
Alan de Bon was quoting is you go it
that seems like a revelation you'd have
on psychedelics where you're like it's
the happiest place on Earth why does it
cost money why are there L because
they're selling you a lie and there so
is reality the whole thing that's why I
like losing and that's why I don't like
gratitude because what is great about
but honestly no I love it because what
is like for example when I made my movie
and it was so hard way harder than I
thought it beat me I was bald in my body
was falling apart really I couldn't hold
food down for a while I'm like in
between there and I'd like lay on my
trailer floor and make videos to my
brother and I'd be like another
wonderful day like PT Johnson add it
again like can barely walk so tired
absolutely hate it can't wait tired so
beautiful tired wonderful as good as it
why am I making this movie that's what I
every day it ended and a lot of people
were doing the like hey dude you did it
you won you made a movie and they're
like when are you going to feel happy
and I'm like no it's view this more like
what it really is and it's like MMA
right so we all think in this business
you get to participate right so you're a
professional fighter you did Jiu-Jitsu
as a kid you got into some striking you
wrestled in high school what am I going
to do for my life I'm gonna fight why I
love it I don't fight because I want to
smash people I don't want to hurt people
but I love this art form yeah then you
get signed by a big contract you get a
little bit of money you wear the tight
rebok pants and here you are now you're
going to be on the main card at Madison
Square Garden you're not the [__]
title shop but you're here your whole
family's coming everybody's proudy look
at you man you really did it well you go
in there and the guy beats the living
[__] out of you smashes your nose cracks
your jaw you don't even get one good
lipin afterwards you're in the locker
room people are not saying you won you
showed up they're proud of you for
trying but you got your [__] ass
kicked they don't want to look at you
and and and and it's hard to look at you
because I love you but you lost our
business is trying to create something
of spinning every loss into a win
because you tried yeah I don't buy it
when you lose you lose and it [__]
hurts and it should because you lost
this is part of the movie but yeah but
agree feel your feelings feel the loss
because it's okay it's okay to go
that [__] is better than me and
I'm I'm not done yeah but you went on a
[__] mountain and so did I and you
have so much gold and it's not because
everyone wants to say luck or [__]
it's cuz you're better at looking for it
yeah and what I'm going to do is wake up
and go maybe I can get better yeah and
without feeling that loss you then go
what am I going to wake up and do I
don't know I might smoke a joint and get
some [__] smoothie and look at this
place and when the waitress goes like I
really like new girl go like thanks and
feel really great and go like listen to
some good music and go wow Moon Dog's
cool how I going Griffith Park take a
hike exercise is neat I'll be home by
the time my kids go to bed or I mean by
the time they come home from school and
then I'm when they're in bed I get to
weird out on the internet right fun day
pass man pass man pass man at 9:00 a.m.
get mad drink coffee figure it out until
3: then do the rest I I hear you so
clearly I'm gonna do what I always do
but it's gonna be very brief please
Richard Roar Father Richard Roar who's a
Franciscan says that Christianity is a
study on how to lose and I think it's so
funny it's a story about a guy who
realizes his Oneness with God and then
they murder him and we've turned it into
Prosperity Gospel like if you if you
roll with this guy nothing bad will
happen to you and everything don't worry
it's all for a reason and nothing more
than you can handle I'm
like it is death and Resurrection but
the death is such a huge part of it and
if you if you read entirety of the Bible
there's so much just like [__] yeah [__]
humanity and exact and that's why it
endures actually and what is unappealing
and what makes my dick go inside my body
is
just it's the dis of everything get
[__] your lips but yes break your
Toth but modern spirituality for me to
go there is going in one direction of
saying like we don't have to deal with
the other half of this and the other
half of of humanity is when we're
talking about you go and you try to get
that animal well the animal is trying to
live yeah you don't always get it or it
kills you or it kills you or it [__]
Rams you and you go like as you're being
a [__] hot shot and telling everybody
like so the way you do it is blank and
then you roll down the hill cuz you
twisted your ankle bad and they're like
now we got to carry his fat ass around
or the group goes or do we leave him
yeah and you're like that is a huge part
of this game that it's just people want
to brush that aside and go it's about
love and light and happiness and
positivity and Disney's the greatest
place on Earth but do not look at that
family where you know Mom and Dad are
going like 80 bucks for the ears and I'm
not even this isn't like a a vegetarian
agenda but like you're eating a giant
turkey leg and you're like that turkey
the hypocrisy of everything drives me
nuts and I have to like people who will
be like they'll talk about what dog
lovers they are how their dog sleeps in
bed with them cuz I'm a little gross out
by animals so I love animals but like I
believe in farm animals right I have two
dogs but I can't believe they live in
our house you couldn't be talking to a
better person but I can't wrap my head
around the fact that and my wife and my
kids those dogs are their siblings and
in the house I'll never win this debate
can I tell you a line that I I don't
even like that I say this but we're in a
safe place I say I love my dog as much
as I can love anything that's constantly
[__] on my lawn agreed there's so
much
[__] also do you have a dog that if
there's like a dead animal rubs their
back on it
it drives me crazy cuz I see and this is
all projection but I just see this
wild unregulated Instinct machine that's
just like like rubbing its face if there
was jizz on the ground my D would be
like he love just the DNA of it and then
it'd come in I'm also working on a joke
right now where I go you ever notice
that houses that make you take your
shoes off they always have a
dog who the [__] are you kidding in what
world are you who are you kidding but
you know what I love it doesn't work it
doesn't work but you know what I love
outdoor cats I love an outdoor cat we
have two outdoor cats uh one of them
Peter self-reliant yes if I I would have
said that if your movie was called Jack
and the bean dick it was [__] their
self I I respect it and and I'm happy to
pay for the food and if something goes
wrong you mean the rewards yes but I'm
also I'm also happy to pay for the vet
where you go like pizza asses in trou we
our cat's Nam Peter so and he's he's a
bad man he really is he's one of the
baddest human beings I've ever met on
planet Earth and when I'm alone with
Pete and I'm sitting outside looking at
him I've never pet him once in my
life never once that's why you guys
understand each other we've had him uh
we lived in Atwater Village probably 11
years ago and uh he and his sister were
kittens under a truck and my wife found
him brought him in our backyard his
sister was eaten by a coyote there's
been so many times where you'll like
hear all the coyotes and my wife will be
like I'm going to put Peter in the shed
and he she can never grab him yeah cuz
he's out there he's moved with us three
times he's mixing it up because the
coyotes know his ass and you don't [__]
with Pete I will every once in a while
I'll see him I'll be in my neighborhood
he's on some random roof and I'll just
we'll make eye contact and my thought
will be like God bless you man do your
thing you're out here living you're out
here living he'll be gone at night we
live near in Pasadena we have real
animals out there one day they're going
to get them and when they get them I
think I should figure out what I'm going
to do in his honor when he dies
something cool this is like the island
where he uh Leo tells the story about
killing the shark and the shark goes
enjoy your dinner that's what Pete will
say he'll grab them with his he's dying
and he goes enjoy your dinner right and
he'll lay back and then or he'll fake
dying and then he'll get one in the eye
of course a little souvenir souvenir but
I love an outdoor cat I can't wrap my
head around that my dog's [__]
aren't covered in my house and they go
on the couch and they walk around and
their tail hits everything they go
outside they're wet they get on the
couch it's raining oh and I'm like
constant paw prints constant and I go I
can't wrap my head around this but I
also know as somebody in a tribe and
that's a family it brings joy to
everybody else so I also have to know
shut the [__] up a little we are so
similar on this I I have to train myself
to be like look at the joy it gives them
and that's good for me that's a type of
losing I have every day cuz I'm like and
I work on it you know what I I Shar this
on the Pod another time I project so
much it goes back to what we were saying
actually about like the dog is
fed and he has a PL and and be fed and
care for if it lived in the back shed
and was outside all day facts which I
would love if we if I had a farm I would
love my dogs so much just running around
work dogs I think they're the greatest
thing on planet Earth I did a peace
score thing when I was 18 and I was in
uh Costa R and I did something really
stupid but they said if you're if
Spanish is bad be in a city uh cuz
there's English immersion no like no
like cuz you're supposed to be really
good at Spanish before you go if your
Spanish is fluent you can go more rural
because the program hasn't been there
before well I grew up outside of a city
and my grandma like my family was in the
city so I was in Chicago all the time so
did this program called uh Amigos deas
Americas we're going to build the trains
down there and I thought like what does
that mean uh Amigos I'm just
kidding could you translate that friends
uh and I thought
I did my uh setup thing and they said
How's your Spanish and I said fluent and
I said and I didn't come to do this to
be in a city in Costa Rica so they said
oh you so you're looking for our more
kind of rural untapped things meaning
this program has never been there so I'm
going to have to be the one to explain
to the people in the village what we're
doing yeah and I I said yes because I
checked all the like 10 10 10 in One
Direction they didn't give me a part
partner so I was dropped off in a
village with no electricity uh barely
running water this is a true story dirt
floors I was in a house that had uh the
ceiling just wasn't fully connected
cockroaches everywhere cucarachas yeah
just like you would literally be like
there a karacha goes over you just go
like this the first night I got there
they said uh uh in honor of you I think
they said I honestly couldn't understand
I'm very dislike like I'm so bad at
other languages you didn't speak Spanish
fluently this was a
[Music]
you you speak more than you understand
noo you were a
liar yes so their day one was your exper
and there no one knew what Amigos deas
America was I didn't have including you
you're were like looking it up in your
well we didn't have at the time oh no so
I get to get to the dogs I get dropped
off there and it's a world of trouble uh
it's a world of trouble they are truly
confused why a green goes there so I do
my only survival technique and I huge
Sombrero I assimilate no I start taking
off my shirt uh I don't wear shoes cuz
don't wear shoes I get it the program at
one point said cuz when women would walk
by all the guys would sit on the porch
they
go and the women there would
go so they it was a call and response
well they all knew each other oh this is
the same there's not there was Eight
houses we should bring that to Manhattan
where they're like hey sweetie and
they're like I know check me out well
long story I get uh they get reports
back saying uh one of the women from
Amigos was with some people and the word
is there's a gringo up on the hill who's
shirtless working with the guys not
doing anything for the program and like
whistling at women so I went full I just
have to survive here I'm just now in
food was scarce cuz I had to ask for it
I would go I was supposed to go to Huts
find a family ask if they wanted a L
train and in response I would get my
dinner you dig [__] holes for I dig [__]
holes for dinner yes I couldn't
communicate the food so I would have to
like CL trees and eat mangoes long story
short I was so lonely there was a
neighborhood dog that was so skinny you
climbed trees and I mango yes real
talk I lost so much weight I have photos
of it my mom said I was never the same
person when I came back she said like
you were always weird now it was a
different weird but I had there was a
dog that I went with every day it would
be outside of the house I stayed at I
would wake up it would be there I would
whatever rice they family had left at it
I would give a little to the dog this
dude was my best I was like loved them
the greatest I would take eight mile
hikes to find a place he was right with
me he was first every once he would bark
and I'm like I'm sure you're scaring off
a snake I would have given that dog half
my food I would have done anything to
protect it my dog now I look at this fat
lazy Suburban piece of [__] and I'm like
all you do is eat and watch TV and
[__] [__] and moan and you stink and
cry if if
uh wrestle with my kids the dog will be
like me you're not a kid you're a dog
you should be in the jungles of Costa
Rica with me helping me partnership this
we've only been having one conversation
cuz we're talking about like a meaning
of life and like finding something to do
and I think both of us are projecting
onto our dogs perhaps rightfully just to
sort of like well you just live at the
spa
[__] [__] you and and I I no we're
talking to a part of ourselves yes
because that would be the case cuz
you're a grinder grind we both grind
rise and grind yeah but look from the
outside from what I know of you you're a
standup then you got an HBO show nobody
gets an HBO show and you got an HBO show
about house sitting and standup and now
your show you're with top standups
you're at whatever that's called the
seller where you're sitting at like the
good table there you're filming at that
table Yeah you got already laying so
that is a rise and grind then I don't
know if that was the one with Jud but I
remember like Jud christened you yeah
that was and it was like oh you don't
get that by being a [__] lazy dog
sitting at home my dog is never going to
have a TV show with J but you just don't
you get that by grinding yeah and so
there might be a part of you that just
wants to sit that gets mad at the dog
but I know there's a part of me that's
really lazy and blah blah blah but the
majority of me yeah is a [__] dog
well I think when we find ourselves
behaving unkindly or or even if it's
just thoughts I'm very sweet to my dog
in fact I overcorrect this dog thinks I
love him so much uh because there's part
of me that does yes but like we if we're
being rough with somebody or a dog I
think we are just treating them how we
treat that part of ourselves yeah and
we're getting a little Glimpse did you
see War of the Worlds
with Tom T Cruz who was he with in that
one was that Emily
Blunt no that that's uh War of the
Worlds was Spielberg I think okay no I
didn't see that one anyway there's a
part where Tim
Robbins is in the movie and uh T Cruz
has to who cares I'm G to spoil it yeah
yeah t it's a great scene it's it's t
Cruz and his daughter I think it's
Dakota Fanning maybe yeah it is and Tim
it's somebody like that and Tim Robbins
is there and they're all hiding from the
aliens and the these aliens are like
your catat they're [__] everything
out there's no fighting the aliens and
they're like we're going to stay here
and we're going to find a way to like
hide and find other people we're going
to like escape and Tim Robbins has
clearly lost his mind and he's like
we're going to make a plan we're going
to go out there and we're going to fight
these things and then T Cruz realizes
the only way out of this is I have to go
in the back his daughter's there close
the door and murder Tim
Robins and great sequence the amount it
is and the amount that relate to that
the parts of myself when my wife in real
life left me right I had to go in the
back with a part of Pete that was like
this guy isn't working yeah isn't that
terrifying but it was so I like that a
lot I actually when I say that I'm not
like sad that I had to kill that guy I
had to do that with my drinking too
there have been parts of me that I was
like can I talk to you for a second and
I closed the door from the sweeter
gentler parts of me my
daughter right murder [__] so so but by
the way this is how we totally relate so
when I said earlier I compartmentalize
yeah so with my wife and kids there's a
part of me that is really sweet and
really different now they'll see a
little bit of the other guy when I'm
pushing them to do homework like you
know when I'm saying to them like I do
expect more for you cuz I want to put a
little dog but I also I want them to
have the dog if they move out of my
house and their thought because my mom
raised me to be tough yeah she raised us
that like the world is a bad place and
the world is scary and as many people
are trying to help you which there are
there's people trying to take from you
and I feel like a lot of people want to
just believe that the world isn't so bad
and the world is really great and that
is true but this is a [__] living
nightmare it's both good is only defined
by bad yes but if you don't think about
the other it's not great when I think
about work so like I'm really B
balancing at home of like cuz I'll do
the same things I'll have big talks with
Jake in the back where you're like ease
up my guy that was too much fat boy
chill hey it's a lot of drinking when
everyone like and for me it's really
weed stop it because I'll go like well I
did yoga after I smoked weed and I'm
like well it's also Wednesday and you're
alone and by doing yoga you went in your
garage and you watched some like lady
teach yoga and you kind of did the
moves and then the music got louder than
her talk so essentially you watched a
lady do yoga while you got high a
two-dimensional lady my man that's not
yoga yeah that was your can I talk to
you for a second yeah and so my talk to
myself is then why are we doing this and
the answer always comes I'm
bored be why because I don't if you if
you need money to pay your bills you
work you grind and so I then get back to
the thing of I haven't done anything in
this game I haven't started the race is
happening I got two [__] B BM knees
and two ankles but I got to figure out a
way to finish I'm [__] broke uh I got
so much I've wanted to say and I haven't
said it and time's ticking I'm not going
to be on this rock forever and at any
second I'm going to get kicked off the
carousel and I'm going to look back and
go I had my dream and I didn't [__]
scrap for it and I'm going to go cuz
once it's over there's going to be a
moment when the town just moves too far
away from you you see so many actors you
love that all of a sudden you're like
whoa what happened to them it just it it
just went a little bit away m I cannot
look at myself if I'm old and sick and
getting into the drug phase and saying
like pump that one of the thoughts can't
be well you didn't work that hard when
you literally were living your dream
yeah it's like well what's the no now I
did understand when my kids were born
there was a big change going on
locations changed the priorities changed
being a dad to them became number one
yeah but you're not a dad 24/7 yeah grow
the [__] up there's times where you can
work yeah and the times are from 8
really when at 3: when they're done but
then they're just watching screens or
doing like whatever they're doing until
about
5:36 so from 8 until 5 [__] work as
if you need it to live yeah yeah yeah
and then once it's over try to switch
out of it without weed or a drink like I
don't want to then be like all right
it's over it was stressful it was
intense I need one cocktail and then I
could be a dad cuz I did that for a
while that's dog [__] so then you're
like no just [__] snap into place and
then the only person when I'm in that
like happy Disney version of mine I like
is I go I don't like the
dog and I'm not going to be nice to it
I'm never going to hit the dog but like
I'll be like this is my family I love my
family I love this and then I'll hear
like and I'll be like you're on the
outside looking in
pal and I know you don't speak English
and I know you can't understand me and I
will pet you when I get in yeah and I'll
make sure you're fed and you'll go to a
vet and I'll [__] pay someone to walk
you a few times a week you're going to
have a privileged life but that doesn't
mean I have to like you that's well it
goes back to your thing about losing yes
and feeling your feelings and being
honest about your feelings growing up
religious I learned to like pave over so
many feelings just look nice and seem
happy yeah and even worse converted like
you've figured it out that's right tot
yes but going off of that and this is
the era that I hate so much about right
now now everybody's always talking about
how it used to be really bad but now
it's great and everybody goes if you met
me before I was in a really shitty place
and now I put it together and the
reality is you haven't the reality is
you're still in a really shitty place
you're just in a better place but for
some reason everybody has now over the
hill of bad and into the valley of
goodness and into the valley of virtue
and everything is going great but you
should have seen the dark days so I'm
going to lead you here with me where the
reality is it's dark everywhere shitty
everywhere it's also great everywhere so
you we have be honest about you have to
be honest so the only people who say
it's great everywhere they always then
say now pay this yeah so I this is
perfect I'm going to lead you this is
your fee once that fee comes you go
that's why you're saying it's great
because that's what I'm paying for
you're paying for 20on Robbins to tell
you that remaining 15% you're paying for
someone to give you their happiness to
lead you to it but the truth is they're
in the [__] just like you yeah I'm I'm
like you I like uh gold and focusing on
good things and asking what I want and
how I want to feel and and getting the
balance right and all of that and I'm
also sometimes I get really overwhelmed
with just how fragile we are like I took
it as a foregone conclusion that you
would show up yeah yeah yeah it's a
miracle that Katie yeah you're toally
100% right we're we're dandelion in the
cracks of the sidewalk I can't think of
that cuz that gets overwhelming with all
the people you love you're like I'm like
no no no what I can think about is my
dog's [__]
annoying well you just said it right I
think would rather be angry than upset
and and Afraid yeah but I do think
that's interesting yeah yes so go so
when I was 15 my uh I dropped out of
school for a year and right around that
time my aunt who was homeless in La
wanted to be an actress had some mental
problems uh my mother had she got cancer
my mother moved her in with us so she
died in our home and my mother said it
was too much for her so she said like
something you could do while you're
around is keep Lucy company so at the
time even though I was told she is going
to die we are past
chemo there is no light at the end of
this tunnel she said I'm going to die I
believed this is our relationship
forever you're really sick and bed I
bring you popsicles we talk you tell me
about what you're feeling we go for
walks you explain how your brain shifts
and that's why you fall and I was like
neat you explain what it's like to start
deteriorating I explain what it's like
to like start living my life and we have
this great thing and when she died I was
shocked really shocked cuz you weren't
looking at it because that part of our
existence well if you I mean if it's
overwhelming it's insane yeah but what I
did get from that goes to this idea of
wanting to be a dog and work work this
[__] does not last forever and that's a
guarantee and there is going to be a
moment for all of us either fast and
sudden or hopefully the things start to
fall apart and you go well I'm an old
car and now this doesn't work now that
doesn't work now I lay down most of the
time now I have a drip now I'm connected
my dad used to say before he died he
would go my life used to be so big now
it's so small and it gets smaller and
smaller and I'm like like oh that's what
would make sense but right now it's
still pretty big cuz he would always say
he would go like you're in such a great
period he's like you know he used to run
a car dealership and he'd be like
looking back it was so fun i' get like a
big deal we got like taxis and he's like
I had [__] citty Chevy on every
[__] cab it was the best and I'm like
we'd be talking and I would forget
because it'd be over the phone he's
about 130 lbs now in sick in bed and
when we hang up he's just waiting for
the next call but then there was a time
he got the [__] taxi deal yeah and
I'm like so if you don't get the taxi
deal let it kill you yeah I'm like cuz
this is the fun yeah yeah yeah and and
the ups and downs the roller Co if it's
all up it's not fun yeah if everything
is great I have so much gratitude how's
every that goes back to my buddy Eric
the maid was in the hotel room we were
standing outside he goes this is
perfect no it isn't in 30 minutes when
we're drinking these Japanese beers and
eating these chips that we just got from
like the Japanese Market the games on
this will be perfect yeah right now it's
a bad
moment and if we don't acknowledge this
then when you say that's perfect I don't
trust you well in the you know I'm a
spiritual person they call that the love
and lighters you keep saying that but
there's a term for it right which is
what love and lighters love and lighters
the the people that are all love and
light all all love and light you see
this a lot in Cults do you watch uh I
love cult stuff love is one or whatever
it was on HB one I haven't seen it yet
no well you know spoiler alert it's the
same as all of them it starts there and
then this shadow that is on because
you're saying I can't see the darkness
yeah so and then it sneaks up on you it
doesn't have to sneak it just walks up
right it just opens the front door but
that goes back to your movie is that
like the feeling it captured the feeling
of like I'll tell you this tell you that
there was a I live in ohigh and there
was there was an earthquake and it it
wasn't big it was the biggest one I've
ever been in but and my sweet little
daughter ran to me and we went outside
and it was actually kind of a fond
memory cuz I got to feel like a dad hold
her tight and all that and then later
that same day we went and saw I've told
this before so I'll tell it quickly we
went and saw Shrek the Musical little
local production of Shrek the Musical
4:00 but the earthquake had happened at
like 11:00 a.m. so there's still
aftershocks so we're in the play and it
was it was great uh you know there were
parts that were funny cuz it's kids but
it was great uh I was unironically
enjoying it and ironically enjoying it
both and every once in while there'd be
an Aftershock and everyone would be and
the people on stage would like and I was
like and I this isn't a dark thought to
me um it's that's life yeah is we're
putting on a play totally and every once
in a while there's an earthquake and it
gets really scary and John Mayer quote
we're slow dancing in a burning house is
is another way to put it but I think the
way out of that isn't around it right
it's through it totally and let let the
earthquake inform and it did I remember
that play the ties of adrenaline and
that sort of stuff to memory and like
all these why we have a hard time
forgetting traumatic things but like
we've said this a million times on the
Pod but ice cream wouldn't be delicious
if we lived forever and if it wasn't
kind of bad for you like we like that
agreed and I I'm totally with it it's
interesting when we talk about death
though so you watched your mom your mom
died no no no my aunt oh I'm sorry you
said your your dad died though yes and
you've seen some of this I just want to
put this to you
kind of getting into the spiritual part
if we want um this Thomas Merton quote I
can't he was a Trapp as Monk and a
brilliant man he had this thing where he
goes and this is Shadow my favorite
Mystics talk hard about the shadow
they're not they're not loving lighters
and they go like we all die alone that's
where he starts he goes we die alone and
this this always gives me a chill he
goes you can pull everyone you love into
your bed with you but it's still you
going on the tobogan yeah and then he
goes
paradoxically the Salve to that anxiety
isn't denial it's to
explore what is it that you call alone
like it's another way of saying that
spiritual thing is who am I or what am I
really so you go deeper you don't stay
up here and go like oh I'm Jake I made a
movie I was on the new girl all that
stuff is we know right that's that that
image in the movie where he looks out
the window and there's the cowboy with
the gun that's us yes even when I get up
to pee in the night I'm thinking like
who yes we're so fragile so there's no
escaping it but that going through that
fear and into the question who am I and
what am I
really is the only way to to go what do
you mean by alone and you go so deep
into your Lon my uh rebuttal to that is
yes um I didn't really finish the point
please jump in and it's going to be new
AJ and that's going to wind you up even
more but when you get into the eye yes
that says I am alone yes what we mean by
the eye which is your Consciousness
which is your awareness which is being
itself and you get curious about the
nature of that being you recognize that
it can't be alone it's the same
everything as everything right so it's
the opposite of alone you could call
that Union with God one with the
universe whatever it is but isn't it
funny that the answer or as I said
earlier the salv to existential
loneliness is Go De as deep as you can
into it and explore that spacious void
right and go like this isn't a void this
is see I think that's a spin tell me um
I yeah I think that's a great way of
looking at dying alone but when you die
and you see the person go from living to
not living it's they're there and then
they're just a body sack body sack and
it happens fast and it's grim and with
my aunt you know we had we changed her
clothes so I like pulled the arm through
and the person on her dead body yeah so
like she died and then my mom you know
didn't want her in those clo she was
just freaking out and so my other aunt
and I like had to take her clothes off
and put a different outfit on her and
the person that an hour
ago was there and part of this Oneness
of all of us yeah this was like if you
ever like a dead animal you go like a
butcher shop yeah you're like the
chicken might be part of the Oneness but
it's also just you know you go to a
Chinese restaurant you see Ducks hanging
that just look like ducks yeah yeah yeah
you're like it becomes an object
whatever the thing was is it's gone and
so this idea of Oneness
possibly and when I was raised I was
named after an uncle who passed away and
the idea was my soul my body would be a
place for his soul to be and we all
believed it and it was all really nice
and good and my mother believes she's
connected kind of a burden though uh it
it wasn't in my family it was more just
like you know he died at 26 on a
motorcycle cycle happened too fast
everybody loved Mark so I was Mark uh it
didn't feel like burden felt more like
fun when my uncles are drunk they get to
go like we're love you Mark and I like
okay you love Jake
too and they did so I'm like win-win
double love yeah but then it started
feeling like the point of like I was
like well this is fun to believe in this
makes my mom feel good this makes me
feel good but is this [__] real when
you're on that actual death bed and the
Darkness is coming I guarantee it feels
better to say I've spent my time I've
gone so deep I believe in a Oneness to
all of this that's a wonderful way to
choose to live your life but it is a
choice because maybe or maybe or it's
just Blackness and I'll give an example
because my dad and I used to have these
big talks like this so my dad was he
left when I was two or was kicked out at
two don't really know the backstory but
he was a he was kicked out uh most
likely I'm just kidding but or he left I
I was pretending like I was
there yeah trust me he was yes but he
was a drugs and alcohol guy and then
when I was 17 he sobered up and then
when I was about 25 we became friends
and I lived with him when my career
bottomed out in my late 20s and we would
just have these we were both insomniacs
so we would have these without mics and
just get into it and let it rip and any
perspective you know we could try try
try and then he finally said one day
he's like let's make a deal this is when
I was 26 27 he goes he goes when I die
let's do something together I want to be
cremated you're going to have some of my
ashes and he goes I want you to break
into WGY field and put my ashes on the
right side of Home Plate scatter them in
and take like in the batter's box like
if he like as if he was a right-handed
hitter my Dad loved the CBS he was the
biggest Chicago sports fan I've ever met
in my lifetime 100 they really meant a
lot to him we bonded over it that was
how we kind of connected and he goes you
do that then take a second if there's
any way that I could reach out to you
say I love you feel you I will do it
then and I he goes if I [__] die I'll
wait if they'll say hey Croco here's
Heaven I'll [__] wait he goes we'll
make this happen my dad because he
didn't raise me always felt bad would
run through a burning building to not go
against his
word years go by I get on new girl I
meet the owner of the Cubs things are
happening I go to my dad when he was
alive I'm like I think I'm going to be
able to pull this off buddy he's like
Jesus [__] Christ Jesus Christ this
is unbelievable I can't believe this is
big big I go you know I sing in the
seventh and in stretch bring him up
there with me he's like I can't believe
we're in [__] rler I go I think when
you die he saying Take Me Out to the
Ball Game yes he's like I can't believe
it's going to happen I was like it's
going to happen uh he passed is away my
brother and I have the ashes at his
house we know it's going to
happen I reach out to the Cubs PR or
they reach out to me about something
about throwing out a first pitch and I
say
absolutely I take the ashes they're in
my pocket my dad's nickname was Croco
Croco his uh where he lived was 425 that
was his address he used to call his
house the 425 Club so I wore in the
Jersey you put your last night I put
Croco in 425 was all to him I get out
there I put a little bit of him on the
uh pitcher round wait they're calling
you out for the pitch yeah and you're
like one second you open a I do one of
these it's in my pocket I go like this
go on the mound drop it like
this well you did it on the mound yes
and then you're supposed to do it on the
batter box story hasn't finished all
right I'm glad cuz you blew it I throw
the first pitch I go shake hands with
the catcher guy whatever take the photo
I then walk on my own to home plate take
some in my hand put it on the right side
smear it in if I'm a big fan just
touching the dirt I go like this I stop
I look up I take a whole
beat nothing then during the uh national
anthem uh there's two guys who do it
playing the
saxophone my Dad's apartment in the 80s
was very 80s single guy who probably
does too much cocain a lot of the
artwork was like ladies playing the
saxophone with no clothes on in
Silhouettes behind like you know like
Shades my on a mirror yes it just trash
my brother and I start dying laughing
tears streaming down our faces and we
were like this could be and then I went
this is the spin I didn't feel him the
spin is he came through the saxophones
right the Oneness of everything to me is
the spin the story feels better yeah
that he did tell me he loved me yeah the
reality is when I was on the field and I
waited the thing that we said he
couldn't do cuz he wasn't there right
and to me that CU he wasn't there you
sounded like Albert Brooks cuz he wasn't
there cuz he's dead cuz he's dead all
right cuz when it's over Pete it's over
we're sex as [__] but you're here now
kiddo good to see you good luck with the
radio show you're a
wonderful but now it's time for me to go
where's my
car
but to me that was that to me is my SP
like that meant a lot to me yeah even
that he wasn't there yeah cuz I'm like
yes yeah great it doesn't make me any
less happy about living or optimistic or
but I'm like right and I'll tell my kids
I'll create something fun for them to do
it and I'll say I'll try my hardest and
if you want to spin it spin it yeah but
if you feel it and it's real that's
great too right but for me I didn't feel
it and the saxop my brother kept going
like cuz I was balling and he's like
this is it man this is Dad and in the
moment to like make the moment better I
went like
absolutely but I'm like no
no we knew what we said it wasn't you
know what I'll do I'll have two guys
play the [__] saxophone I'll go like
too far of a spin my
guy if he had that would be pretty cool
yeah if he did it would see I don't
really put too much
stock
in in that like even if you were like
and the saxophone name was Croc I I
don't really care yeah there was a time
in my life that I loved Miracle stories
or things like that and I'm not
bullshitting
you I'll just say it and see how you
respond I'm more interested in how you
respond the awareness that your dad was
is looking out your eyes right now the
awareness that my dad was is look at him
what does that mean there's only one
awareness yeah you and your your dad are
as connected as anything agreed meaning
your dad was a wave he took the apparent
image of Croco yes the wave Crest
sizzled onto the beach got pulled back
he's [__] gone yes but the water
water is still there aged so when I tell
my daughter yeah there's nowhere you can
go that I'm not with you toally I mean
that 100% literally and I will not be
telling her when I die where would I
want my ashes I don't know it's the C
star I'm just kidding no no no no no no
don't curse me don't curse me cut him
saying no it's a scary place it's a
scary place just say Comedy Store and
cut there and we got him now that's what
we're bearing him maybe
Largo but I I I it's not to dis uh
discredit your I love the experiment
yeah yeah but your
dad when Raman maharshi this great
Indian Saint died that his he had cancer
or something and his followers were like
don't die like heal yourself
miracul guy and he goes where could I go
right it's this all all the biggest
truth sounds so stupid right but there's
no time there's no space and there's no
separation it's just this yes and that
even that is saying too much so your dad
we can honor that he's gone and be like
where could he go right where is this
nothing that we're talking about yes but
here's the other side he's also gone
he I would say he okay so the Zen uh the
I believe it's Chinese Zen they say
death is like a vase yeah and the air in
the vase and then you break the vase and
the air that was in the vase goes into
the air yeah it's gone the the vase vase
yes the vase is is so much nicer I know
and you said ant which I appreciate I
also say ant um the the vase is gone
yeah it's another Paradox yeah your
dad's gone yes and he was never here
here i' I'll go even a little harsher
cuz you love the harsh an illusion
cannot die right well so then Disney
Then Disney is the happiest place on
earth I agree I'm about to pitch them
something so I agree I'm just kidding so
but that idea like but that is
significant because it's two ways of
looking at what do you mean by that
so he is not gone because we are all
everything and we are all here at the
same time and that is wonderful and
you'll never leave and I'll never leave
and everyone who's ever been here has
ever been here and we're all part of the
same thing well the other thing is my
dad and I D in football games would text
and FaceTime and talk the whole time and
laugh our asses off well that's gone so
I could say well I feel him he's here
and he's still here sure but he's also
not and that but also I think it's both
ends I I'm so with you yeah no I sorry
keep going but I'm okay with the thing
of he's gone because he died and when he
was here it was great dude we've only
been having one conversation it's D
close it's the same stuff he's gone yes
and John Mayor is not Jerry Garcia but
this is great too but it's also great so
a buddy of mine said about his dad had
died my buddy clay Allen and when my dad
died I was really sad and broken up and
he goes here's what's hard you and your
dad your relationship was a book and the
chapters were being written and he goes
there's no more new chapters being
written that book is done and he goes
but the relationship isn't over it's
just now oneid
and I didn't get it at the time I went
like yeah but I want the chapters to
keep going yeah but what's ended up
happening is things will happen that
I'll know he'll love like the podcast he
would love how much I'm turning this
into a business he would love how the
number get there with the Cadillac but
he would love it yeah and he would go
like so expl because what I love about
it is the business of it is I love the
direct to Consumer I love the idea of
[__] if this audience continues to grow
with the pace it's growing I might do an
indie movie and try to release it direct
to an audience from a website and cut
everybody else out and go if there's
enough tell let's do a poll how much do
you think this money this movie should
be rented for I think you could do
entire shows direct to audience yeah and
I'm like but before you used to have to
wait for them to tell you how it was
doing yeah so they would break down
their reports and you would go like how
we doing and they would go like we'll
schedule the call in nine days yeah and
I'd go well I made the [__] thing I
would like to know exactly how it's
going this is is a direct thing so the
actual piece of art my dad didn't care
about the thought behind the business so
I will do moves that I will think oh he
would [__] love this story and it
feels good yeah but I don't get to tell
him so it's a new way of telling it it's
still sweet but it would have been so
[__] good if he were alive to hear
this he would love it then I could hear
about the [__] dealership we could
have two hours and he would go like this
was so fun and I'd go I agree and I go
but I got to hang up cuz I'm in the
driveway now bye and he go bye call me
later later bye we'd hang up and I'd be
like it was the best that's gone yes and
to say it is but it isn't because we're
one thing to me is finding positivity
where it's a [__] huge net loss and
it's a [__] kick in the dick yeah and
you go like it sucks yeah and maybe when
one day I'll die I'll see that [__]
we'll go like the John pron when John
pron when I die I'm going to get to
heaven start a rock and roll band
smoke a cigarette that's mil long have a
vodka [__] seven up see all my I'm
like wonderful image but the reality is
that John Prim is gone now and it's so
sad because I love to hear more music
yeah and it is the same but it's how you
like to look at those sameness and for
me even though I hate the feeling of it
I love going like I don't love but I
like going I just miss him and he's not
here yep and if he was it took me a
while to finally delete his contacting
my phone cuz he was a top five best
friend yeah to go like well I don't get
to call him right he's the only [__]
who wants to hear about this yeah
everybody else goes yeah another uh yeah
business thing yeah and they're like
boring and I'm like yeah I hear you he
loved it I'm so glad you brought a piece
of your dead I really I was like eating
it I loved it what a gift you gave me
thank you and all of us I hope I'm with
you I'm actually this whole conversation
is about Paradox is about the whole
thing we've been talking about both and
I just want for fun my optimism is
actually incredibly Bleak in fact when
I'm afraid I'm going to die yeah say I'm
on a turbulent airplane I say an
illusion cannot die so what I'm
comforting myself with is I never
existed meaning Pete is an
apparent a a momentary abstraction of
the Oneness that kind of to experience
itself and play with itself we're
playing a game you be you I'll be me
we're vibing I love this this is so fun
really yes so this kind of like the in
the infinite can't know the finite yes
so it creates the finite and then it
places itself in the finite as a
character so it can experience it
because Oneness can experience Tess so
it creates this whole thing but it's not
real but it was all but a dream it was a
dream this is God's dream and you and I
are thoughts in God's mind so it's good
news bad news yeah yeah yeah I totally
get it Jake you're not real that's great
and it sucks cuz you're not real that's
right and Jake's missing his
dad is real a dream has relative reality
right a hallucination has relative
reality you can be tripping balls and
say there's no giant trying to eat me
but relatively there is so it's all both
and and anyone who's trying to tell you
it's not it's just this and it's not
that yes there's so much mourning a lot
of my spiritual practices is coming to
terms with my fear and my anger and my
despair it's not just going like I'm
just the air in the vase I'm like oh no
but you have to get really honest and
fierce it is like going into a cave with
a torch I I forget which Mystic said it
but he's like there's like Jesus or
whoever you you got leads you up the
mountain and then they go that's the
Peak and when you go up he doesn't come
with you and you're not there and Jesus
isn't there and God isn't there but but
there's a there's something but you
can't even talk about it but it's it's a
heartbreak they say Enlightenment is the
ego's final disappointment right good
news bad news yeah but an illusion
cannot die is only yeah I mean I flatter
myself thinking that that's comforting
yes but it is to you cuz that's how
you're choosing to do this game that's
right and I'm saying I'm a wave and I'll
just go back in the ocean but that makes
you feel better that's right and so for
me we have to own both but you also you
have to own what works for you what
works for me is I don't think we're that
different than a chimp and so I don't
want a chimp being like in a tribe being
like this other chimp is really taught
me a lot that's my healer that's my this
this person has led me down this train
of thought these other chimps really get
it but that chimps don't get it that
group over there I'm like yeah yeah we
all are going to come we're on this rock
this is what it is this is pretty great
and then it's pretty terrible and you're
right like a d it could go fast and life
can turn like this you get one call from
a doctor and you're like man this
[__] dream turned into a nightmare
right but it is all that same thing and
it ends really quick yeah and so for me
it's not a dream it is fiercely real and
if I'm on a plane and I have that moment
where it goes like this I think like
[__] my kids are still too young yeah
like it's just I'm not like but it's
both I have that too I don't want it's
called spiritual bypass yeah what we're
talking about is your dad dies and you
go but he's just the air in the vase I
would say Jake you're spiritual
bypassing right you're not feeling it
and Val my my wife I know I've said that
a million times but Val is the one that
always just goes put your hand on your
chest where is that grief yes can you
let it get bigger feel it go towards it
and that is the the uh the exact core of
what the movie is supposed to be about
don't talk we got to go self-reliance on
Hulu January this is Hulu you January
here on Hulu and take
Al and Magic mine and that's for you
modern mammals that's actually a great
shampoo we have similar hair you love it
you'll love it do you not wash your hair
I mean I use yes you can't wash it right
I can wash it what do you mean you do
wash it yeah your hair doesn't look like
[__] if you wash it I don't give it too
much thought I I go to CVS I get shampoo
and I put it in and it doesn't look like
[__] it looks pretty good thanks could
look way better it look better yes JK I
regret bringing an ad into this but what
were we saying uh the core of the movie
is that yeah and so in terms of just
telling the story it's feel things in
your life so you can get over the girl
because I don't want to make a comedy
where it's about all this other stuff
yeah so it's I got dumped I'm in a low
spot and I'm trying to do this and
everybody's basically saying you have to
feel and what the point of that is and
the reason it took this big game to get
there is you could die
no I know and it's got you and then the
holy the whole Arc of his character is
not that he's going to knock on the door
and she's going to answer it and they're
going to be happy yeah she might say
you're a [__] weirdo and I don't know
it's real or not and you're not for me
and his stomach is going to go like oh
or she's kind of weird or she lied about
or she's going to be in but whatever it
is he's excited to knock on that door
and feel what happens cuz all there is
is right now it's really happening and
if you lose and you're that [__]
fighter will put ice on your wounds but
don't say I don't hurt or for me the
thing where it's like or yeah what
happened I won by doing it and I'm as
much as the winner as the winner because
we're all the same thing and we're all
no he's the winner why cuz he [__]
kicked my ass why cuz he was better at
me than at this weird thing right now or
I cuz I got in my head the bright lights
hit me as I was walking up I saw Shila
Buff and I got thrown I and Lance Bass
was in the front row and I was like and
then I had a bad show and it's not a
dream it's reality and why did it throw
me I don't know but I spent the whole
[__] time think I did a one thing
with me Max and Lamor and Ben Affleck
was on the stage in the watching was one
I was terrible yeah and afterwards I
thought like that's a net loss and they
were like oh was fine I'm like we
weren't good the entire time I just
thought like here's Ben Affleck yeah
yeah and I could pretend not to be a fan
but I'm a fan he's heed you he changed
my whole head space he he Afflicted you
we're the same age Goodwill Hunting was
such a a shift for I agree I'm from
Boston oh interesting so I saw Ben
Affleck in Harvard Square after that
movie came out and I loved it so much I
worked in a movie theater I I cut scenes
from the film from the trailer I don't
know yeah this is my version of what did
you do you did something similar like it
doesn't matter I had frames from the
movie and showed it to him in my wallet
and he he initialed them he he so sweet
what was the project that got you or the
person that got you wanting to do this
game do this yeah the whole thing what
was the thing that you were like oh I
love
that it's a great question I think one
of the answers is Goodwill Hunting one
of the answers is the book Sign Language
Jerry Seinfeld's book because it was
clean and I was religious and I was like
and I didn't know I could do that there
there was I'll go darker I can do this
and mother won't disapprove right like
real [__] Freudian stuff but now my
mom hates my comedy and I couldn't be
proud
her you know what I mean what an
achievement what an arc imagine if I was
still going on stage and being like soap
yeah yeah [__] that I love I love that
my mom is like pey sweetie why do you
have to talk about such things cuz I'm a
grown man I'm a grown man you [__]
look at
it or I just go don't watch it I
actually it's it's it's it's a point of
Strife in my life but if you were
watching my movie I'd be so proud of my
character I know maybe that's weird to
say but the Peete that was going it was
a Little ma melan yeah where I was re
reading sign language and I was like
this is my way into the pirate life
right while getting approval that I
still need cuz I can't do it without my
parents thinking I'm okay yeah now I can
yes but it took Sign Language by Jerry
that's really cool man I was reading
portions of it to her and she was
laughing I was like I got it yeah we're
in business we can win here and then I
did that for like seven years and then
my wife left me and then I got
funny cuz I was like that was my this is
what are we talking about what is this
this is ending this is insane it's on
fire so what am I doing this for this
other person for totally why am I
letting this character loom so large I
don't even like this exactly and it feel
that that's why like forgive me this is
one of my passion at talking points but
I'm like I do feel honestly and maybe
you feel this way as a filmmaker that I
could do something I sometimes joke
about doing a comedy special called is
this what you wanted yes and I just do
an hour of what I think people want
totally and I I I don't think I'm
flattering myself I've been doing stand
up for over 20 years I think I could do
an hour material that would be broadly
widely accepted I think you should so
but the you think I should yes I can
it's death to me so I so I that goes
that's like being in church again well
so mine's different so uh I've had a I
had a really big realization in this
process of this movie and going back to
the why why we're doing it all and I
fundamentally feel as if audiences have
gotten forgotten and I fundamentally
feel like we have performers have made
it all about us and our process and what
we want and our journey you mean Han
shot first what's that George Lucas
recuts the Star Wars movies because it's
about him and it's like it's not it's
for the fans and Han shot first but I I
I fully feel like we have all we've
gotten so into in between our own years
and this town and the celebration of
this town and our Awards and our credit
and who's cool and what studio is cool
and what critics like you and if a
Critic likes you you're cool and if
certain cool people like it and it's
good that means you're good but if these
people don't like it that means you're
bad and if this person says you're funny
then you're funny but if that person
laughs maybe you're not funny and if
that person goes dude you're a filmmaker
great or if they go yeah I like that
little thing maybe it means something
different and I've been so wrapped up
into this [__] and I realized in
doing this if we are anything you go to
New Orleans you're walking down you see
like eight kids dancing and for money
and you stop sometimes and you go like
Jesus Christ these [__] kids can go
and you're drunk and you throw some
money in and they go you're like great
and you look and you're like these guys
are making real money and then you walk
down a little bit and there's somebody
else who's not as great someone's
playing the saxophone you look at their
case and you go like not as much money
and I'm like we've forgotten that's what
we are I don't view us as [__]
teachers I don't view us as guiding
people to anything I view us as we give
people a break and we entertain and I'm
like and I love thinking like that I
love what you just said I won't forget
that yeah I feel like every podcast
there's like one or two things and I'm
like I'll I'll remember that in 10 years
and I think that was it but I'm going to
counter by
saying here's when I if I did the
special is this what you want yes I
would be doing an impression of other
people oh I got you oh I thought you
meant what so here's the difference I
thought you always trying to do
something that will blow them away I
thought you meant doing what you love
but you know they're going to love it
too no no no I am captain I cut precious
bits my favorites but I'm going to tell
you something WR that I no no no I'm
glad we circled back but Conan name drop
told me he was like what he thinks of
show business is a room with 10 100,000
people playing instruments yeah and some
people are putting down their saxophone
and picking up a keyboard and then they
now they're playing the Blue Man Dro
Blue Man Group drums and he's like all I
did was I banged my triangle and he's
like I just did that for 10 years and
then finally someone went what is that
what is that noise I've been hearing
that for 10 years that's more my
approach meaning I think more fans or
whatever
meaning for its own sake a broader
appeal is coming for me that's a goal of
mine but it will come from banging my TR
I'm I'm waiting for someone to go like
oh this guy Pete's been great you know
what I mean that's but it's the same
thing with the street performer that
dancer the one you give them the money
it's because they're doing exactly
what's working for them but they're
entertaining the [__] out of you so it's
you you see when you see when someone's
doing something that you're like oh
that's purely you but I feel like what
the the big thing that I've forgotten
about or at least not thought about as
actively as I am now is at home I'm a
relationship with my wife and my kids
that's my real life at work I am in a
relationship with the audience and they
matter as opposed to I'm in a
relationship with my creative self I
hear you and I have to do what I want to
do and what I've been dreaming to do and
if I do that you will come yeah and to
go well they're here right now yeah and
this group has supported me since new
girl has started and I appreciate it so
rather than me just go well where I'm at
here there's a thought that I'm having
of like well where are we at yeah where
is the thing that really works for me
that really works for you and I'm like
and that feels like a really fun game in
terms of like with the podcast you have
a direct link yeah and you're like oh
like we were doing a lot of like sex
stuff that was really making me laugh
and we started feeling like people were
going down and comments were like it's a
lot like be like I'm a mom I'm literally
doing uh dishes uh while my kids are
sleeping lot of orgy talk yeah and then
we would like you took the note sure
yeah but then look they don't go away
but we're like literally we're talking
to producer Kevin and we're like maybe
we'll do a little less like that and he
goes yeah I kind of agree it's getting a
lot then all of a sudden you start
feeling a change and you go oh this
thing is alive and we're doing it
together and I think that thing is alive
with everything until it's not yeah like
now my movie is not alive now it belongs
to the audience but I'm like oh this IDE
why I said at the beginning like I wish
I could start it now I've now seen it
with enough people I've heard enough
stuff I now know what I think it's about
and what the majority of people think
it's about yeah so I'm like now I'm
ready to start making it yeah yeah yeah
and I'm like ah [__] it's over I started
laughing while you were talking I love
everything I'm going to play this clip
do you mind no it's from new girl it's
you and it [__] killed me dude and
I've never done this on the show but my
Val loves new girl it's not that I don't
like new girl but she loves new girl I
appreciate that and she sent me this
clip of you pretending to be stoned and
I just just want to play it for you my
wife sends me a lot of videos Leela Lea
ice skating okay here it is
dude I'm going to preface this by
saying she sent it to me because this is
me when I'm
stoned when she doesn't impression me
when I'm stoned I go like this I
go I go ask me anything cuz I think I
know everything I'm so high I go ask me
anything I'm willing to go I know
anything and you're kind of that way in
this going you're not an expert I am
nobody knows we're Stone if we didn't go
then they would know you're saying that
if we don't go to the party they're
going to think that we're hot oh the guy
who's never done weed it's not the
proper thing with smoked weed you don't
do weed that's you said it listen to me
first order of business we eat their
food okay then you look at the pool a
what a great pool I wish I wish I could
die for
Rings because if you were stoned you
wouldn't die for rings
um I was just thinking of this
impression who am I
doing what am I doing alucino maybe so
then you get home you eat some pizza
trust me I just thought of every single
possibility it's over that is me you
going like going who am I doing who is
this so do you remember that no that was
just Damon and I improvised it in Cross
coverage goofing around that is so funny
is that what you're like when you're
Stone uh no no no that so Damon and I
are old we did a movie together we did
we became very close so we know how to
make the other he's one of those people
when I was talking about Vince vaugh
Damon Wayne Jr is one of the funniest
people I've ever been around one of my
favorite humans on planet Earth and when
we would do scenes we would cross cover
it and we' or be in a two shot that
means two cameras at the same time and
so everything that's happening is real
so it's live so the when they edit it
they can just put a whole take in going
back to like making someone's
performance and theame that's not
happening no the game that he and I
would always play trying to make him
break one of or he would try to make me
and we know how to do it so he would
know like who is that you're trying to
make him laugh I'm just going to his
sense of humor of like this is I know I
can get Damon on this and whatever I
have to say I will sell out for Damon
and going back to the audience bit my
whole game and it's why going back to
the Dell close so I miss too it was make
your partner funny do the scene this and
that and so my whole thing is I want to
make the scene partner laugh and I want
to make this real and I've realized man
I should be thinking about the audience
too yeah yeah yeah and I was like I've
missed that I win on a day like that if
afterwards when they called cut Damon
does like his big laugh and goes like
what the [__] was that and we're
cracking up and then I thought forgot
about it cuz I felt like it's over I won
and I'm trying to do that recently of
like yes I want the scene partner to
laugh but like imagine if all the energy
was thinking about when somebody watches
it at home alone yeah and I was like I
don't I know it seems like a goofy thing
to keep saying it's really significant
in my head yeah and I'm like I think
I've abandoned them for years I get it
yeah I you're you're catching me just at
the right time I'm thinking about that
money in the New Orleans right guitar
case yeah interesting it's so important
it's so but you've got to be there
you've got to be doing what you do yeah
yeah yeah cuz you see the people who
fake it you'll be like you're really
talented but like I'm not putting money
in your guitar playing I'm not into you
I always say it's like a bad date when
someone's doing an impression of what
they think a date should be totally
totally wrong but the good date is is
like it's just magic yeah it's like and
you're being real yes not to be weird
it's kind of like this like I'm not
trying 100% you and it's like My Dinner
with Andre like why is that movie so
captivating it's because you remember
what like two people I'm Wallace and
you're Andre if we're doing the comp I'm
Andre I'm W Andre the Giant
inconceivable this was incredible wait
he was in a movie with Andre the Giant
yes of course he was and then he was in
you think at any point Real Talk he said
it's my Dinner with Andre the Giant and
I bet Billy Christal did and everybody
else did and while Sean was pretty
serious was probably like yes that was a
different project that I
did but this is this own project
humorless yes that was a different film
yes well that was a serious film and
this is you guys clowning around with
prosthetics and me and Andre don't have
Prosthetics my
impression that is so funny I okay my
impression of Andre the Giant is him
seeing some fans notice him and he goes
do you guys want to say
bonjour do you guys want to say bonjour
pretty good it's okay but it's fun to do
just saw on
Instagram that he once drank 130 beers
at one sit in and once on a plane he
went to the bathroom and it smelled so
bad that people were like having like a
crazy reaction to it and they almost
landed the plane
early he messed with air traffic but
like enough so that they most and look
could this be another lie possibly I
believe it to be real yeah but the he
went to the bathroom it smelled so bad
that it became a thing on the plane and
most likely he had to go like I'm sorry
I'm sorry I really had to go I should
not have had the fish or the 50 fish cuz
he did he would eat I mean he drank 131
beers in a sitting that's you could
Google that I know another one where
they were he was getting surgery for one
of his various wrestling things and they
said we're going to give you anesthesia
can you imagine being the
anesthesiologist for Andre they said how
much can you
drink uh before you start before you get
drunk and I think he said something like
30 bottles of wine 30 beers I start to
feel it well he would do a thing you saw
I saw cuz I used to be obsessed with
Andre the Giant yeah loved Andre I wish
that dock was better I don't know why
but it was still fun it was fun but I
wanted it to just be this this is still
fun and it wasn't somehow photos of him
with a bottle of wine where it just
looks like this yeah and the fact that
he would drink like nine of them yeah
I'm like I don't know why that makes me
so happy baly slime that's him saying to
Hulk Hogan yes when his back was hurt
but he gave in with the crowd yeah yeah
yeah well this is great yes really fun
nice to meet you self nice to meet you
self reliance is on this platform Hulu
yeah you should watch it we watched it
we loved it thank you and Katie watched
it and she said she's still thinking
about it which is a great compliment
that's fair oh no no no she loved it and
it stayed with her is the compliment
yeah it stayed with me as well um the
last question we ask everybody we have
all these but we've done enough man
we've done it I feel it we're done uh
can you tell me the time in your life
you laughed the hardest or one of the
times you laughed harder than you've
ever left yeah my uh just just quickly
well I don't I mean it's a lot it's my
brother and I so my brother and I have
been doing bits since we were kids we
used to do characters around the house
we created we like sketch was everything
for us growing up and he and I could
commit to characters for months on end
so the what's the hardest I've laughed
it's been some game that we've done that
like every voicemail we leave each other
every time we call it's an ongoing bit
we've been talking about how we're
currently writing a sketch show together
that we started in the 80s it's called
the greatest sketch show ever written uh
there's so many layers to the bit we've
never written a half page we'll never
start every project is he's like so
maybe we should do a podcast we're like
I go well if we want to take over the
entire [__] market and he's like I
guess I'm ready for it it's it's going
to be 100 hours without any edits called
still chatting
we'll never start any of them but we'll
get into ribs for every once in a while
it'll be just the right moment and I'll
be like something will happen and he'll
go I'll get the call and I'll go hey and
he'll go new idea for still chatting
hour 30 I'll just be like and he'll talk
for like he CU he's my brother he won't
be respectful in pause so it'll be like
six straight minutes and then he'll
finish and he'll go like I gotta go and
it'll hang up just like you just made
this drive home amazing your dad yeah
yeah yeah totally I'm in the driveway I
got to go okay
okay incredible yeah great fun thank you
for doing this thanks for having me you
say keep it crispy it's the it's just
it's how we have a sense of closure the
guest says keep it crispy keep it crispy
can you say it is your character on new
girl keep it crispy can you say it is
your character in safety not guaranteed
keep it crispy can you say it as your
character in self-reliance keep it
crispy can you say it as yourself keep
it
crispy this is me realizing you're not
an actor keep it crispy now here's how
i' would say on the podcast keep it
crispy best keep it crispy
ever you made it you made it you made it
oh yeah you made it you made it you made
it oh yeah you made it you made it with
you made it with oh yeah you made it
with you made it with you made it with
all yeah